come on
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
check this out
[Music]
all right
here
[Music]
everybody
right there
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
let's go
come on hello everyone this is your
daily dose of Internet how
what is your boy
[Music]
[Applause]
I would lose my mind are you
kidding me I don't understand this
goddamn game I don't get it
baby
he has to move his brown man whoa whoa
you could do that I can't move your
crown man like that
[Music]
I saw this
obviously bud
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
POG Champ's five your favorite creators
favorite creators chess tournament or
something like that uh we've had a
wonderful a few days of me being away
from the commentary Booth but now
unfortunately uh they have replaced a
wonderful person with myself I'm Levy
Rosman and I am joined today by the
second most famous Swedish individual on
the planet uh behind of course the ABBA
music group and that is Anna kramling
Anna how are you
I'm doing great loving but I'm really
not the second most famous person in
Sweden do you even know anything about
Sweden
Sweden Swedish House Mafia I
we got slots on we got Ikea we got it we
got so many things Lavia I mean we have
so many great artists that are from
Sweden
bye exactly you should know this well
you know what I'm sticking with that
introduction
um the most famous chess player to have
ever come out of Sweden top five top ten
I've had gas but I'm sorry Mom oh that's
true wow this is uh this is uh this is
off to a fun start uh so I'm going to
put a big graphic on the screen now to
remind everybody why we're here
um this is also a very fun time of
course because we are officially in The
Knockout stages of POG Champs so we
started with 16 players uh and we will
remain with 16 players because we have
both eight Champions and a consolation
bracket now the big one on the screen
right now the championship bracket top
left you have a and b uh A1 plays B2 so
the winner of group a plays the
runner-up of Group B and so on X you see
papa Plata down there and then we have I
did a thing Tyler won those are groups c
and d and of course surviving the crazy
commentary uh that had to happen between
uh X you see and tyler1 yeah how did you
survive by the way because even watching
it I was scared
honestly I don't even know myself I was
very nervous for That interview
um but I just realized that we just
gotta let the players just let their
anger out you know there was nothing me
and Andrea could do to stop it they had
to scream at each other and that's what
we got and it was amazing so I knew I
just had to stay quiet and just look at
Andrea and just just pray to be honest I
really hope one day that if any top
players play a match they just do that
we just let them have the mics and we
just go at it like Nate Diaz Jake Paul
press conference they throw water
bottles at each other they talk trash
they talk trash about everybody else
they talk about cleaning pools uh it's
gonna be a great time and they might
play each other as you saw they're in
the bracket now let's put up the
consolation bracket uh we have not
forgotten about these players this is
the uh well they call it the losers
bracket they are they are losers on the
chessboard but definitely not in life
they are fantastic wonderful creators
and individuals on their own uh and uh
top left of course we have a versus
bottom left we have of uh C versus D
some of these players had a very rough
go around uh in the group stage that's
just how it goes sometimes daily dose of
Internet unable to even get on the board
but he is easily a number two or number
three favorite in the constellation
bracket Anna Let me just ask you is uh
is virtual the one that you're looking
forward to the most because everybody
was terrified of him and somehow the
other contenders in group b managed to
deal with him it was very close but
can I just say something he wasn't Group
B okay they put him in the hardest group
out here there are other groups that
were much easier and yes I've been
coaching virtual and yes he got put in
my opinion in the most difficult group
so I think honestly that everyone in
that group is strong I mean daily dose
ended up being the person with at least
points but he's still a very strong
contender in the consolation bracket so
we might get a group b winner as the
winner of the consolation bracket we
don't know
sorry that that wasn't me yawning that
was me doing a copium emote uh live on
uh
yeah I'm sorry uh that's just yourself
Levy I heard he's saying in other
commentary matches you were saying Group
B is the most difficult group
I was the only person that is happy in
group b is ghastly okay and we will talk
about Gastly because he's actually our
third matchup of the day today his
rating was like 600 in this in this
group and he won the group he was the
lowest rated I think very close with
daily dose and he managed to win so yes
he's underrated and everybody was
terrified of virtual uh and you know
what else everybody should be terrified
of no this is a very bad transition but
the live final
of pogchamps five is going to be in
beautiful sunny totally not polluted and
not gridlock traffic Los Angeles where
the players are going to enjoy the the
consolation and the championship racket
finals uh participants are going to
enjoy a wonderful time in Los Angeles I
mean I that's not I don't actually it
might be a terrible time but there's
going to be great weather and for the
first time it's going to be live uh
exciting right that's we've never had
very exciting very exciting are you
going there Levy
yes uh Ludwig's team hasn't booked my
plane ticket yet uh can y'all book my
plane ticket and in the meantime let's
talk about I don't know I'm
I don't think maybe I'll get fired fire
I really I don't know that's the thing
when you work with lead it's it it's you
never know uh love you love you lad
um today's matches
um squeaks versus foosli that's the
constellation quarterfinals uh and uh
then the next consolation quarterfinals
matchup we have for you is Jarvis versus
daily dose of Internet that's going to
be very very fun and then our main event
of the evening the third match is
ghastly versus Frank that's a big one
that's our very first knockout matchup
in the championship quarterfinal uh
group a versus Group B Frank the higher
rated player but actually the lower seed
because he had Sea Dog in his group uh I
really missed a lot with foosli didn't I
when I when I was gone that matchup was
insane she did get on the board she had
one point after the group stage Hannah
would you like to uh tell
um tell me because I wasn't exactly
there what did it feel like to watch
History unfold
to be honest I wasn't actually uh doing
commentary then I think it was Andrea
and Danny if I remember but I was
watching it in my watch party and let me
tell you Levy it was so stressful I have
not seen this amount of stalamates in
one camps match two spell mates in
a row when I thought it was impossible
for another settlement it happened but
cutie was able to win in the tie breaks
but uh was able to take it to tie breaks
and therefore get one point
yeah I've never seen two stalemates in
back-to-back games I mean cutie
impresses me all the time and this was
just yet another example uh so fusley
did get on the board but that's a very
tough group uh and she is our first
matchup of the day let's take a look at
that matchup we're gonna start with
squeaks uh squeaks
had a had a tough group with tyler1 and
xqc he's a twitch streamer he's a uh
speedrun streamer and he was actually
the 2023 speed best speedrun streamer uh
nominee at the streamer Awards where
Anna and I both work uh great venue by
the way organized by a person playing in
this event it's fantastic right just
amazing
and squeaks also was uh the 167th
fastest Mario 6
they got it that's just such a mean like
can you imagine like 167 in the world
grandmas there he is maybe it's really
good Levy I mean I think it must be
really good imagine being the 167th best
chess player in the world this is this
is so tongue-in-cheek of them but can
like they really couldn't have found a
nice third Arrow to just talk about like
for example let's go to the fusely
player card all right look at fusley's
player card she's glowing the edges of
her hair are purple streamer YouTuber
content creator for 100 thieves she's
got over 10 million streams on the
platform she's a musician this is her
second box Champs appearing she's an OG
she played in the very first one she
gave chess a shot before any of you
bozos in chat gave chess a shot she was
an early adopter she was probably
playing chess Anna before you were even
streaming full time right like I feel
like this was early 2020. this was
before we had Anna kremling uh all the
time and uh this is her starting soon
screen so
um I really like it
is that accurate I feel like you went
totally full time sometime 2020 or maybe
that's I don't know it's been a long
three years but she's been she's been
playing chess forever
she's playing chess for a very long time
and that is true love you I actually
started streaming full time around like
2020. so it's crazy she's played online
chess almost longer than me because I
wasn't playing so much online chess back
then so she is an OG and I am so excited
about this matchup against squeaks like
I really don't know what's gonna happen
but there's gonna be chaos Levy that's
all I know it's gonna be great let's
remind everybody what that format is
they play two games well they don't have
to I suppose one of them could just
forfeit after one they play two rapid
games it's the best of two so if it's
one to one they play a blitz playoff the
winner of the best of two moves on and
they should add probably one more uh
small thing here this is officially the
first time that the loser of a match is
gone
we never speak to them again and we
delete their chest.com account when
their match is over no yes one of those
things is not true maybe actually it
depends on how bad their game is uh this
is a knockout we have officially entered
the knockout stage and this is
coinciding with one of the biggest
knockout chess tournaments of the year
which is called the World Cup there are
two massive tournaments going on one in
which 28 12700 players are playing for
the ultimate glory and this one which is
watched by thousands of more people
because the games are more relatable and
they are played by your favorite
streamers and commentated as well and
I'm excited uh this is going to be great
and this is better than the World Cup
I I feel bad saying this as a as a chess
player but I haven't really watched a
lot of the World Cup but I've watched a
lot of pug Tams and I'm very excited for
this yes E4 a Karo Khan defense from
foosli amazing I don't know who her
coach is but uh they're they're a good
coach and I'm not saying that like as if
I am uh secretly coaching or anything
but you know coaching her I I'm not
coaching I mean my videos might be
coaching her but you know I don't want
to take the credit the Karo Khan defense
very nice opening the problem with it is
if you're a beginner and your opponent
doesn't actually play into anything
specific You'll Play like E6 and then
you'll Block in your bishop or Knight F6
which is what a lot of beginners play
here
um so we'll see what she does
yeah I'm actually not super oh E6
I called it right like it you know her
Bishop is blocked but she's positioned
still totally fine right yeah I mean
it's very solid always when you see this
little pyramid of Pawns uh defending
each other it feels very solid and it
feels like nothing wrong can happen in
the beginning but what is wrong I guess
it's that her Bishop is gonna get stuck
but I'm sure she'll be able to get it
out
she's gonna be totally okay because I
think a lot of beginners don't even
exactly know how to exploit this like we
see Bishop D3 right that's not the most
accurate move but he played it because
he he couldn't put the bishop anywhere
else good for her she's gonna move her
Knight she's gonna Castle he'll probably
Castle or he'll play A3 uh
wow wow is she gonna take or is she
gonna keep the bishop knowing that it's
better than the Knight uh because she's
gonna take no she she kept it yeah she
kept it I wanted to pop in on her stream
just to see her thought process but she
played it pretty quickly and she'll
probably go here and here as well so we
don't have to pop in yet uh we could see
oh this is awesome consolation bracket
stand up damn this is oh they're better
than half the chat look at this it's
amazing stuff I can't believe it I mean
what is going on what is this opening
it's so solid this could literally be a
much higher level game than what we're
seeing yeah
this is going to get played at the World
Cup tomorrow little Bishop D3 Knight C3
night at night F3 Karo Khan let's go and
now Levy E5 and get the bishop pointing
towards the kin
yes
the squeaks know that that is the best
move and then you secure that and you
know you'd love to Kangaroo this Pawn
white would be much much better if they
had the center and the space
um
he's doing it
squinks became a grand master oh my
goodness now does she know that she
should not wander to the edge of the
board because frequently if the Knight
has no way back it could get trapped or
it could get traded off and the
structure will be damaged oh she's
throwing a Haymaker but it's it's it's
mistimed oh it's a capture chain Pawn
takes Pawn takes Pawn takes G7
yeah it's very common I feel like
whenever someone is attacking you to
want to attack your opponent you want to
keep on attacking but sometimes you just
gotta move the piece just gotta defend
it
I I think we're gonna pop in on on Foose
is that is that the plan right now we'll
see what she's thinking she's do it she
seems to be uh
quite happy with her position
yeah she looks pretty happy to be honest
I mean she's like kind of smiling and
kind of moving her head around singing I
don't know
yeah I didn't know if we were going to
get audio on her but I I don't hear you
um I have an idea
okay
no
never mind what if I did this so so look
I find what if I push my queen here
right and then
so say my Pawn eats it then I go in with
a spicy boom right
and then spicy boom no game of course
but okay spicy boom yes you can't
because my Queen's behind it and then
what if he is going for a spicy boom
Stone we should all be Brooke
and then I eat his real sheep she's
trying to make it work it make no
mistake it does not work whatsoever but
that's you know that's chess like you
have an idea it's like an artist you
know you you build something it doesn't
work you got to rebuild it that's just
life and by the way uh squeaks uh we are
on her stream right now there it is the
move has been made let's go back to the
analysis board
um um oh no foosli in that time he moved
his Knight out of the way but she didn't
that's the problem always with when you
do another attacking move instead of
just defending your piece it's so easy
to forget about it at this level yeah
she
she saw it he moved it and then she just
she just castled and that would have
been a good move but she should have
moved her Knight and she's not even
taking this Pawn what's she what is
going on
what she wants to go for the spicy boom
Levy she wants to push the pawns and get
all the pieces onto the attack but the
spicy boom was that she's not even she's
just she's literally running it down mid
by the way like she's running it down
mid now she takes but her King is open
but squeaks his Knight is hanging he's
gonna go here and lose it is that what's
about to happen can we pop in on the
squeak stream let's see
doing great I think I'm in a great
position
okay wait that's good because the pawns
are doubled up I'm pretty sure I saw a
video of Levy saying that you want to
hurt Pawn structure
uh okay wait I'll go here yeah but does
he know his Knight no no that's not what
I told you to do don't don't that's not
what I said in my video don't lose the
night did you not play that move damn it
it's really good I've gone through
keeping your pieces alive oh thank God
oh thank God he didn't play that move
okay all right come on
you better
all we have to do is checkmate
that's it it's so simple
what do you mean it's
so much the Queen the queen is coming up
Queen H5 oh you're right oh you're right
Queen H5 she's gonna take the Knight
because she just took one night and now
Queen H7 made oh my God
still got this lovey oh no oh God
did you teach about checkmates about
that H7 Checkmate in your video do you
know if I go here
[Music]
let's just save our night for right now
didn't even put his Queen there this is
a crazy move but I'll do it
and he's putting a knife bring it back
to the analysis board oh my God
oh my God huge developments the stream
is a bit behind it it's there's a mate
squeaks as a mate and he's done it it's
over it's over what it's over
oh my goodness can we get a live
reaction of the Checkmate now we're
gonna go back to the Stream
[Music]
laughs
boom
let's go
let's go baby
oh my goodness
wow can I just say that I feel like he's
really improved like this game he played
very solidly apart from forgetting about
that one night but still I
you know what it was all a worthy
sacrifice and you know we can even
analyze it real quick
uh because you know we space our matches
out by an hour and that one took seven
minutes
um it was very funny how he just did not
literally none of my reaction was caught
by the way because I was like running
out of my chair and meanwhile you know
he uh
he yeah I was just yelling but I was on
the floor basically when he played this
movie because he gave a whole big
analysis of playing this move when his
night was hanging and then he went here
uh which is definitely not good
uh and and Anna pointed out Queen here
and queen here not right away obviously
because because of this but Queen H5
would have been nice and then and then
foosley got played this which some
blunders are not like others that one
blocks the bishop
and just by looking for a check in this
position
and then another check it he just won
the game literally just boink
and boink
and that's yep and that that's all you
know that that was the first game that
was it that was the first game but that
was actually amazing I mean I really
think that squeaks played very well he
kept on doing a great attack and it's
sad that it was just that foolishly she
wanted to just develop and move but
unfortunately it was one of the few
moves that allowed this Checkmate to be
honest so yeah so so it just happened
but big props just squeaks for playing
such a great game he is lower rated he
is maybe a little bit the underdog this
match but he's showing that he has great
power to win this to win this so we're
gonna see if he's able to get a draw or
win this next game as well yeah I have
no idea what to expect I basically
realized that the first five or six
moves of the game between these two
players is gonna be solid and sound and
it's going to be based on good
principles uh and the rest of it is the
equivalent of like you know putting your
shirt over your head and just trying to
run just on a field and you know maybe
you'll run into a fence maybe you'll
trip maybe it'll be great and then you
know you'll you'll have a great time so
total chaos ensued uh she almost took a
couple nights he went in with the queen
attack yeah fusley you know uh
it I think she just has to before she
makes a move she's just got to think
what is the most annoying thing my
opponent can do like how can they put me
in maximum danger and yeah and I'm like
you and I have played many chess games
first of all against each other and
second of all against other people and
uh some blunders are not like others
that blocked the bishop and it's game
over
yeah yeah no it's one thing when you
just do a little blender but this is a
little bit of a bigger one but I'm sure
she's learned her lesson she will know
that she should never open up her King
like that she should never take uh with
the pawn and get her King to be all
lonely like it was there and I'm happy
that squeaks was able to capitalize on
your video you know and learning that
the King was unsaved now that the pawn
structure was like that and he went for
the kill I I'm good I'm not gonna lie we
could watch the replay I don't think he
said a damn thing about the king being
open but I you know I might have
misheard he said double pawns are bad so
he proceeded to undouble them because he
knew he's his next move undoubled the
pawns for his opponent and then lost the
full piece so that's the thing about
Chess you don't actually have to know
how to play it you just gotta think you
know how to play it and that's the
beautiful thing about it that's what
we're doing we pretend to be good at
this game meanwhile players who have
played it for 30 years are currently in
Baku Azerbaijan and they are playing it
like on a very serious level and we're
just all memeing around here we're all
having a great time uh yeah I feel like
the the better you think you are at the
game the worst you actually are uh a
hundred percent right and the worse you
think you are at the game is she
pre-moving the opening
wait what did she do it when she did
this the other day too but I thought it
was because she didn't know how to
unpremume what is she doing what why is
she removing the opening what's she
doing
E5 winning the bishop could that happen
I mean but she could like lose all her
pieces because if he plays wait Bishop
takes Bishop Bishop takes Bishop from
squeaks well he doesn't know she's
pre-moving
oh my God
this is crazy
Bishop
one more chance
okay okay now now I have to do some
stuff okay so let's see what he's done
uh okay okay I mean yeah I feel like
every time I okay okay now I actually
have to oh my God okay so now I can't
believe it worked fossil Castle okay so
all right do not move the Knight to D2
that is the typical final London move
you don't want to do it because you can
take a bishop here okay okay that
and then
he takes with his Bishop I take I kind
of just like this this is
this position
does she know do you believe that that
worked I feel like she's watched a lot
of Hikaru maybe she's watched a lot of
Chess videos and she wanted to do what
hikara does
I Hikaru has never done that so I don't
know it's not that exactly yeah I don't
know uh I don't know what she was
watching but uh by the way uh I I wonder
if she knows the next game plan which is
of course to get the queen out and then
go for an attack uh that was oh and and
he did in fact take had squeaks played
Bishop takes Bishop at literally any
point he would have won the bishop for
free because she was pre-moving the
opening so by a miracle of God uh he
takes it right as she stops pre-moving
and now the Knight can come here finish
up the development stop this and squeaks
should not go here because Pawn takes is
a fork but that's a very common mistake
uh players make but the best move here
is to take
and then go back here and try to win
this but let's
let's see let's I
get you want to play guess I'm not sure
that's gonna happen
you wanna okay I was gonna I was I was
gonna say let's play guess the move here
but I think we're gonna
we're gonna go check in on squeaks
what's squeaks thinking about
we can do that after Levy or I take she
takes
[Music]
I think that's a bad move
thank you
then I take he's looking at it he's
looking at Bishop takes
as long as he's not looking at night
takes just don't take with the Knight
oh
[Music]
I don't think that's a good move
I take
and then she goes here I take here
wow she's got oh no she's looking at
night she just got two moves in a row in
his calculation
oh good move nice let's bring it back
let's bring it back that's a bad move I
should have thought um the hard thing is
when you're a beginner every move you
make that you don't know if it's like a
winning move you just assume it's a bad
move so right like he took and he goes
oh that was a bad move it's the best
move but it just mentally he's sitting
going you know it's not a good move this
is fine
um and and this is good for black
because the bishop is sort of blocked it
was better for white to play Bishop
takes so that you could try to play F4
and create some sort of attack but uh
Knight E4 is fine and I wonder what her
next move is going to be that that's
that's really what I wonder right like
are we expecting F3 Knight T2
I feel like F3 is a very common move
you'll see a knight that looks very
dangerous up in your alley and you're
kind of like okay I'm gonna push push
the Knight away I'm gonna go F3 kick it
away and see where it goes and I feel
like she's been trying to get a lot of
space and stuff I can see her going off
three
F3 makes sense it's a simple move also
of course Knight here she might go Queen
B5 you just try to like make aggressive
Queen moves and attack things that's a
good move oh C4 yeah okay yeah the idea
well I don't know does she see that it
was that her idea can can we see what
she's thinking she just played it on her
stream I think she streams on on YouTube
so she's a bit delayed
um
that's okay but maybe not maybe
streaming
oh no it does say YouTube forward slash
oh wow good move from squeaks by the way
all right this is incredible Levy can I
just say what is going on this is like
the highest rated highest level game
I've seen in so long go here
don't no no Anna just complimented you
no
no Fork just
before Queen B3 instead of Queen A3 she
complimented you firstly she said it's
not
oh that's a yeah that's a tough move and
and the worst part is you can't even win
the night like the Knight is just it's
trapped in the corner but I also really
worry
oh well not right I worry she might lose
the queen no no don't move the Knight
like that then no no no no put it down
put it down put it darn you speaks
to move it there's no way to get out of
this huh put the Knight down
oh thank God
oh she realized
no
darn you those clothes oh wait wait wait
wait no wait there's got to be a way out
of this
dude Slide the queen up one square and
just trap tonight that's the only way
okay okay at least I caught it
um let me think about this right so say
I moved my queen I have to move my queen
I don't want to lose my queen so if I
take uh if I take uh if I just go here
maybe
he goes here
all right he's in the middle
um and that's it I just lose a knight
that's okay but maybe I can take a
better position than this maybe no don't
do it here but then his King just takes
and there's my queen either way what if
I were to push forward what if I were to
do something more aggressive what if I
were to go somewhere where I could then
take his piece afterward so if say he's
in there I could go nah it's doomed I
think I just have to I think oh my God
oh my God please please
don't make it worse oh my God why is she
moving the knife she was like no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
great at the Rock
I moved into the wrong spot
maybe he won't see it he doesn't see it
of course of course it
oh
damn
oh love you I feel like this game is
being pretty quick as well
yeah yeah we'll just you know we'll have
to
just have to just have to sit and talk
about the twitch drops that we have for
40 minutes or something I mean that was
fusely what
it was going so well C4 was a good move
deflecting the pawn and night before she
had to keep her Queen safe
she let the night in the good news is
for those of you that are watching this
and fusely I don't know if she's gonna
watch this back the tape back
um
it this Anna this is all tactics like
all of this is just common night and
Bishop and queen and forks and stuff
like that
mistakes like this go away
and
this has very little to do with a
person's actual abilities at anything
and mostly just pattern recognition and
I think if fusely really wanted to she
could
grind hundreds of puzzles and you know
just not get hit with forks but
no I agree I think that she's seeing C4
moves great deflection if she saw that
the Knight was hanging I mean all of
that is great she just needs to grind a
little bit more of puzzles and not hang
her Queen because I think it's actually
being uh the queen that's been one of
the the issues in previous matches as
well
oh yeah yeah she
it's tough for her I mean it's tough
it's tough
uh her Pawn is getting taken and the
thing is you know you could lose the
Rook for the two nights I think we're
gonna pop it on squeaks see how he's
feeling
uh with his big advantage
[Music]
such calm music
yeah he's
he's a sleeper to win this constellation
bracket
[Music]
oh try to be annoying I mean we can
start trading
she didn't take his yeah I did not
realize that she did not I just assumed
yeah I think that's the one thing she
she needs to work on if she wants to you
know I keep improving to really always
remember when pieces are hanging and
really do puzzles to learn that live
yeah we have to find a way to check
I'm listening to squeaks
surely I won't squander this
no this is this is a hanging Pawn I feel
like this is just a good move wow right
here that was crazy Vision it's a spot
that
hmm
Queen D2 is the best move I think in the
position because I'm going to start
taking I'm telling you scream squeaky my
Grandmaster overnight this is a whole
other level than I've seen before on
squeaks if I get my Rook involved
[Music]
oh yeah he's gonna get the Rook involved
he sees it he knows the queen needs help
so he's gonna bring his Rook down the
center line there and he's going to team
the rook and queen up on the second Rank
and uh short of a total disaster I think
he will win I I have a prediction
actually but fusley's got to kind of
play along and not blow and let's just
bring it back all the pawns
um
it looks like a mate already
but I don't know how to checkmate
don't I have to get rid of every single
piece I feel like he knows he wants to
bring in The Rook yep Rook there
uh and uh
uh Rook T8 is uh he wanted to play this
anyway and the problem here is now The
Rook is gonna get traded and I my
prediction was going to be that he
brings the Rook down here he takes and
then he goes here
uh and then he loses his Rook but now
that's unlikely and white just doesn't
have enough material here uh one way to
secure a match Victory is to take all of
White's pieces because even if you
stalemate which would be foosli's third
stalemate of the event uh you still win
the match because you get one and a half
out of two so
yeah yeah that's a very safe way of
doing it but I think it's gonna bring
down the rock I mean oh okay
yeah I don't I don't think he's actively
thinking about stalemating
um but but that is a good thing to have
in your back pocket
pocket for sure and now Queen E2 or
queen F2 and then get the Rook behind
the queen and then check them in on G2
with the queen
exactly right G2 or a ladder mate or
this is nice
yeah or anything
fusely looks extremely excited I
I I don't
I mean I I love I love the attitude and
but yeah it's good it's good to see that
losing a chess doesn't have to be
painful yeah I think it's painful I mean
when I lose in chess I'm not smiling
like she is I mean she looks even
happier than squeaks right now I know
squeaks just can't even believe uh
can't even believe you know he's just
Rook D2 oh man clean
although your prediction might become
true with the Rook takes G2 and then
losing The Rook on H2 I'm not sure if
that's not gonna happen but we'll see oh
well that's that it's heading that way
squeaks don't go Rook H2 you gotta win
on the light squares here so Queen here
and queen here if he plays Queenie too
that will show high level understanding
kind of like paralyzing the white king
uh Queen E2 is by far the fastest way to
win uh F2 also and then F3
but E2 is a high level understanding
just immediately seeing that you could
go there just don't go here because you
lose the rook and uh that would be bad
if he goes Queenie too I mean Levy I'll
I'll like literally like leave my chair
like
well okay he played the more human one
but but this move is is a delay like
you're threatening this you don't even
realize what you're threatening here you
just kind of get closer but this would
have been a really high level
understanding because it shows how your
pieces work he kind of wants this but he
can't get it but she might even go here
right like she's kind of out of moves so
she's just gonna push upon
hopefully he doesn't hang his Queen and
his Rook
and then this is this is easy
um yeah no I don't think it's gonna do
it but I just need to say something
people are now saying in chat that
squeaks is like way too good to be
important like he's so good you know a
few days ago but people are saying you
know the squeaks wasn't as good so this
just shows how much some of the players
are improving throughout the tournament
as well I think that is by far the best
and most solid match by squeaks
yeah squeaks is on a Redemption Arc
which I think is important I think he uh
was a little bit I think he was a bit
you know like the best player in the in
the in the group was obviously xqc and I
think he was also probably terrified of
Tyler won
I just want this bishop out of here is
that crazy for me to say
[Music]
I don't care for this bishop at all
I don't like it
I want it to go away
[Music]
how was that controversial
what of course it's fine to say you know
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
just said don't go there
we need a compilation chess.com social
media crew look through the podcast
games
how many times I called the moon
not bad at all 90 accuracy
let's go let's that was very
good go yeah that was that was a very
nice game our first matchup of The
Knockout stage of pogchamps five is
officially in the books and we have our
first semi-finalist and that is squeaks
with a resounding two to nothing win
with an average accuracy of like 80 in
the two games
well amazing stuff absolutely amazing I
think it's played really well and this
unfortunately means that fusely is now
eliminated from POG Champs but she's
fought really well throughout this
tournament
yes uh it was a she had she had a tough
go the average ELO of the first group
was something like 800 and then her
first opponent was no walk in the park
in the constellation bracket he was the
one and only squeaks uh trash talked by
both members of Group C in their exit
interview yesterday he's on a path to
Redemption and now I have a soft spot in
my heart because he he quoted one of my
uh you know quips uh today in his
thought process so now I'm cheering for
squeaks I need to say something you know
what firstly said the other day she said
that she like would like play chess with
psychunan and put like your videos up
and then like they were would like watch
her videos and hear them so she also
watches your videos so yeah I just
wanted to say that
well he probably watched them more uh
you know I don't know they got to send
the watch hours I don't know who to
cheer for you know what we won't be
biased but we will give props because
squeaks two nothing can't have it any
better than that I think we're gonna
show you some brackets now uh because uh
we have our our updated bracket uh we
are we are actually going to I forgot
that we interview people after they win
I forgot about that been a while but a
vacation I'm jet lagged uh we are going
to bring uh squeaks on uh for an
interview uh because he won the match
and that's what we do we're not going to
ignore him and uh very convincing
display we'll be right back with our
first winner of the day and I am going
to drink some coffee
[Music]
thank you
team
s
August engage in a battle of Epic
Proportions against some of the most
Bodacious artists history have ever seen
behold Raphael the prince of painters
doth seek a fresh Apprentice Dosh thou
possessed the prowess to impress him
Michelangelo a true renaissance man
painter sculptor architect and poet doc
possess a myriad of artistic talents yet
one wonders can his creative genius
translate to Brilliance upon the board
of chess
prepare thyself for a game as dramatic
as the Baroque paintings of Artemisia
gentileschi one of the most expressive
artists of the 1600s
I renowned sculptor Donatello stands
tall as one of the most important
artists of the early Renaissance his
unique blend of creativity Aesthetics
adaptability and patience maketh him a
challenging foe Lo Leonardo da Vinci
known for his artistic talents
scientific curiosity and innovative
ideas is the very embodiment of the
Renaissance he is not only among the
greatest artists to ever live but also
one of the greatest thinkers May a
fortune smile upon thee create thy
Masterpiece on chess.com cowabunga
[Music]
foreign
everybody
[Music]
foreign
thank you
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
fog Champs 5. we see there the winning
celebration first
match in the consolation bracket
concludes squeaks is the winner was that
the same reaction or was that too real
was that that was two reactions right I
don't even that anyway
it was two reactions that they were very
similar what's up squeaks welcome to the
show congratulations on the win
oh thank you so much you know I was so
excited I had to play out my reaction
I'm basically an NPC but I'm I'm so
happy my heart was pumping the entire
time I mean it was just a blast
well speaking of NPC uh I'm gonna just
start right now that's actually a good
idea you know all these NPC streams
nowadays that might be just one of the
celebrations you just I don't know I'm
just gonna propose you a business idea
we got time to kill
yesterday
that's why the soul has left my eyes oh
I was on a plane like have to I did not
know I would have watched I would have I
would have I'll be there for the next
one there you go I'm glad you did you
make money
did you make money yeah I made money
yeah I made money but at the cost of my
soul how much money oh you know I don't
know
was it was it like worthy I'm not sure
oh it was not worth it
what was that
it was not your last time doing an NPC
stream or will we see more squeaks NPC
streams oh last time I'm ever gonna do
it last time I might stream honestly
that was uh it was a lot no that was it
there's no way I'm doing anymore I'm
sorry to say well I was gonna ask you uh
because you today like you played so
good that was like absolutely amazing
your accuracy was really good
um was that your preparation doing an
MPC stream or like what did you do to
prepare to play like this well something
that I think helped a lot is I haven't
played chess since I played against uh
xqc so like what really charged me was
everyone was talking like cutie
said that I was so bad at chess xqc
Tyler won they said I was like dog
so all of that just fueled me until it
congealed into this chess momentum that
I was able to just unleash today so from
this point on I promise not only are you
gonna get big wins for me but I'm gonna
have a high accuracy I'm confident in my
chest now from all the hate
that's amazing people in chat were
saying that you were playing so well
they were hyping you up so much it was
amazing you played so well I uh thank
you so much I was actually I was saying
squeaks during the show like you know
yesterday you were catching a few Strays
from you know and I and I and I xqc was
the clear favorite in the group like
he's got a lot of experience but maybe
it was just Tyler one's muscles like I'd
be scared if I played the guy I feel
like if you get a repeat versus him you
know maybe it goes a little differently
you know it happens but uh
differently I'm scared of Tyler if he
sneezes I'll get blown away let alone on
the chessboard I'm terrified I'd want to
be in LA with Tyler horrifying right
that's what I thought see that's that
that was my prediction but it was a uh
it was a good
good match couple of matches you gave
away the night in the first game it was
a very funny moment because you said I
say double pawns are bad in my videos
and then you let her undouble the pawns
and take your knight but was that a
Gambit was that like strategic to get
the attack you wanted the checkmate
everything I do is strategic Levy um but
here's what I would say I just say
things to sound cool in the moment
without knowing what I'm saying so I
knew that you were doing commentary so I
was like you know what Levy shout out
like maybe this would be like a cool
James Bond moment or whatever
um so no I think I just accidented it
into uh double I'm doing the double
Knights honestly I just wanted to sound
cool Levy all right it it was so cool I
I'm I got the clip saved so you know I I
appreciate it and uh now I'm rooting for
you I told Anna live on the show I said
you know what he he watches I'm I'm
cheering for him so uh you're the Dark
Horse now uh Levy was your number one
fan he got so excited
um I wanted to ask
about now being in the it's gonna be the
semi-finals yeah in the semi-finals of
POG Champs who do you want to play in
the semi-finals
um well I don't really I would want to
play probably let's see I probably want
to play cutie Cinderella because cutie
said I'm so bad and like when cutie and
I actually have been playing chess like
we played chess like we played like 10
matches together and I only took like
one game off of cutie so I would love to
like have this sort of be like The
Gauntlet where I come back and I've come
become so much better that I could
eventually beat cutie Cinderella who
helped me a lot in the beginning to
learn
yeah I'm ready to go and after you beat
cutie you'll go to you'll get a plane
ticket to LA from from Ludwig it's like
the perfect you know and then and then
we'll see you there you're gonna be live
for the finals any more pressure there
or does it feel you feel good you feel
motivated it's the uh oh I feel the
teacher becomes I feel so good oh no I'm
so motivated it'll be like a real karate
kid moment I I'm just ready to win I'm
gonna take the lose I'll be like the
best loser so I'm ready to hold that
title close to my heart
beautiful stuff beautiful stuff uh
squeaks ladies and gentlemen that was a
very very fun interview thank you for
kicking us off in the uh knockout
portion of our uh of our POG Champs
coverage uh I personally wish you all
the best for the rest of your matches
too and uh you know Anna wishes you uh
but I wish you even more of the best all
right I I am a fan
yes it is
you know he he I got name dropped so you
know I'm I gotta get his autograph now
when I see him in Los Angeles it's gonna
be a beautiful moment um squeaks uh this
was a lot of fun uh and uh keep a close
eye on cutie versus Jenny because you
might have an opponent very soon so oh
I'm ready I will thank you both so much
appreciate it
it was a pleasure it was a pleasure so
I'm I'm about to cry I'm about to cry
[Music]
foreign
thank you
two one
three two one
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
POG Champs 5. we are lucky enough to be
joined by foosli for an interview as
well uh how was your pog5 experience
talk to us uh expectations versus
reality about the match and also thank
you for playing in pot Champs again you
were like an OG you get you gave chess a
try before it was cool
that's um yeah the first POG Champs was
very different for me versus this one
the first one I I did I was able to like
you know train for like two weeks prior
um I was losing sleep over it because I
was so stressed because you know just
they they always people always correlate
chess to like intelligence for some
reason you know and I always I was just
so afraid to look stupid like I was just
so afraid of it and so I I was up late
studying watching videos all that jazz
and then for this one I was really busy
beforehand so um I I didn't get to to
study as much but I I will say I watched
a lot of your videos you know so
everything I know it's because of you
Levy
I told Levy that before he was sweet
squeaks was saying that during the game
he was like oh I've watched you know
Levy saying all of this and I was like
Levy foosli watches your videos too I
heard that in another interview she's
also your fan well I I I've been on the
right side just like how to do it how to
win with the London I was I was watching
that video right before my game
yeah not during that that's very
important no no not during the game
sorry no tutorial to open during the
game it was before right before it and
then and then yeah the opening the
opening versus squeaks was good yeah
it's just and even in the first game
like the Karo Khan it it's very good but
um yeah like especially if you don't
play uh actively for weeks before and if
chess is not something that you do a lot
um it can happen and squeaks also is
kind of like very much on a Redemption
Arc right now because his whole group
has been trashed like the whole c d q d
uh tyler1 X you see have all been trash
talking him so uh yeah I mean
I am not gonna lie I didn't
I didn't hear you back
not I didn't hear he was but I was
watching a podcast this morning and they
were they were they were talking and
Ludwig and kitty were talking about how
like they watched his game and how it
like he was bad and I was like maybe
I'll be squeaks maybe I will but and
then so I lost him and so I feel a
little bad but then I watched his
interview like just now oh I could I
couldn't make out the words but I could
see his face and you see how big of his
smile he had on his face and he was like
this and that and his smile and honestly
it was for I did I threw for for his
happiness so you know I um you're
welcome
yeah
I think he was very happy
he was so happy yeah he was very happy
it was cute
I wanted to ask firstly uh there was
this one gamer you were doing all of
these pre-moves it was so exciting you
know me and Lobby like our hearts were
racing we're like is squeaks gonna
figure out that she's premoving or what
was that all about
um so I realized from the first game I
he was like way better than I thought he
was so I was like hoping that I could
freak him out a little bit you know like
just move super quickly because
sometimes like at the beginning of a
game like when like if you know a lot of
people like take their time but if my
opponent is more like like every time I
moved they already moved it starts
throwing me off because I'm like wait
they they're they're so good they're
moving so quickly like they they've
downloaded the game and so my Hope was
that he like because it's a London it's
pretty like um standard like all the
pieces kind of go the same way every
time I played the London which is the
only white opening I play against
everyone in this match it's been like a
mirror matchup every single like I think
all of my games have been like to a t so
there hasn't been any like crazy like
you know I take your Bishop this or
whatever at the beginning so I just
figured that was my mental game is like
to to be aggressive and to like freak
him out but he didn't yeah he didn't he
still yeah Charles is all about
psychology so that was really good that
was really good and it worked and you
got a great opening that game
oh thank you so much yeah what about the
mid yellow game
no but that's yeah that's all
hundreds of rounds of puzzle solving and
again like if you're Rusty at all or if
and yeah this POG Champs didn't have as
much of like a training Arc as some of
the first ones did because it's hard
it's hard getting all these creators to
like agree to time slot some coaching
and everybody's also doing like 10 other
things nowadays my my question was going
to be uh you obviously play basically
like every game right so uh and also
you're in a lot of uh group uh collabs
and like if they play everything from
like among us to fall guys to like four
different FPS games that I don't even
can't keep track of all them because I'm
totally one-dimensional in my content uh
is chess like the hardest and most
unique one in the sense that it is so
for lack of a you know it's not a good
reason but it's so correlated with
intelligence like you could fail
massively in any FPS and it's just like
a viral clip but something about Chess
is different right because yes you feel
like it like attacks your ego a little
bit it does and what I don't know what
because there's so much like thinking
right it's like it's uh it is very
different like just because someone's
very you know smart smart high IQ
whatever would not mean like they might
never have played chess or they might
not pick chess up very well it's a
different muscle you're flexing but
something about chest feels like an
attack on your intelligence when you're
bad at it
so that's why I've always avoided it or
like I'll randomly get like very
defensive during a chess game like I'm
like very competitive like it brings out
like something in me
um that I'm like I cannot lose to this
person playing chess because then
they'll think I'm stupid I don't know
what it is about Chess I know it's like
not that but during the first POG Champs
absolutely I was like I I felt that very
much so and I don't really know why this
one I was a lot more relaxed and once I
just said like it's okay I don't have
time to practice I'm just gonna play it
out
um and have fun the games are fun like
even losing the game is fun it's like
little puzzles figuring them out and um
you know thinking about like like I
always struggle
I always think I can take a piece but
then I forget that they can take that
piece so I'll like put the bishop or
like I'll Fork two pieces I'm like yes
and then they just eat it and that blows
my mind they're like I just I forget
such calm like such obvious things
um and then like I'll forget like a
bishop can move backwards like it goes
this way so sometimes I'll just have a
bishop and there's like their Knight
right behind it or like a rook right
behind it and I'm just only thinking how
do I progress towards their side so all
right what was the original question
that was that was the question I mean it
was like yeah it's all
it's all it's all practice and just
hundreds of repetitions it's the same
way like if you don't go to the gym for
a while and then you go you just get
sore immediately and you're like or you
might even hurt yourself if you like
lift wrong uh it's the same with Jess so
I wanted to ask because there's a like
yourself there's also a few other
creators that just like literally every
game that is popular uh whether it's
like a phase like fall guys are just
like long-term FPS games you all play
all the time and I and I do wonder if
chess is and I I was wondering if chess
is unique because it's
oh yeah it's like it can be really awful
to play like it can be very demoralizing
or
it's just very like it feels just hard
like like almost like there's no way I
can just jump in and be good at chess
like you need to play so much of it
um and and then uh I guess yeah I I'm
much more of like a a Hop Around And all
I'll play chess if people want to uh but
it is definitely like a very separate
from the other ones you know I play
Among Us in GTA and fall guys valorant
whatever
um chess isn't usually at the top of the
list
nowhere in the middle she looks so happy
playing it you know and you're playing I
did enjoy it like it's fun to talk out
my thoughts and like during the actual
thing there's something on the line
um it is fun in that way I would
definitely do another I think I would do
another five Champs probably as long as
there's like no pressure on it I like I
just show up for the matches
um yeah I had I had fun I actually did
um I'd say the first one was definitely
more of like an intense experience for
me because I committed so much time I
remember staying up till like 2 A.M 3
A.M just like watching videos and
learning like the big basic chess Theory
just like stuff like that and I started
I started to like feel the Improvement
because I unders like you know you go
from knowing absolutely nothing to her
like oh I'm not supposed to move the
same piece twice or a castling or
whatever basic stuff so that first
initial excitement and then I realized
I'd kind of like hit a wall like I'm not
gonna get much better without practicing
after a certain point
um and so then I haven't played in three
years so I actually just think I'm I was
better back then three years ago because
I hadn't played for three years uh and
then I stopped practicing so yeah and I
actually one wanted the first one I'd be
E Rob and now I didn't beat anybody but
I have a point because of cutie and she
could her lack of ability to to
checkmate that was legendary yeah
yes that was awesome uh well listen uh
it was uh it was great having you as a
participant in pogchamps five and
pogchamp six Redemption Arc straight to
the top of the Champions bracket no
sleep for three weeks grind chess uh you
know uh it's gonna be it's gonna be
legendary or just play for fun thank you
also that too that also is gonna be good
um foosleep appreciate your time very
much and uh we will say goodbye to you
until the next chess event uh it's been
uh it's been great thank you so much I'm
out of the tournament
yes I'm done yes oh yes
oh I'm so sorry
I wonder if we can just like not let you
be playing like you no no no no no I'm
okay thank you so much
thanks for joining us
that was great I I wouldn't even be
against it we could like we could just
slot her in uh we've got two more
matches coming your way we've got Jarvis
and daily dose of Internet on the other
side of this break and we've got Gastly
versus Frank as well in the Champions
bracket and we've got two
I have been informed that there is not
going to be a break I love just saying
things and then completely reverse I I
like it's so fun because it's like a
little game I get to play with the
audience it's also the producer is like
hey no breaks we ran out of time because
you're you went too long in the
interview and I'll be like oh my bad I'm
not I'm I'm just a dude in the T-shirt
talking about Chess beautiful stuff Chad
uh Chad how y'all doing Anna how you
doing well we gotta talk about the next
matchup I think but you know just a
little just to check in doing great love
you I'm doing great you're doing great
we're all doing great I hope chat is
doing great as well that's a great
interview with supposedly it was really
fun and I'm happy you know she's so
she's so positive and I'm happy that she
could still be positive um even though
uh she now lost but we're gonna go to
the other matches so Jarvis versus daily
those yep starting with uh daily dose uh
of Internet we he we just removed his
legal last two names
um he's got over 16 million Subs but
this was made at the beginning of the
tournament so honestly he's growing so
fast you might already have 17. uh he
does that say six wins and 35 losses in
the book wait what
is that accurate I
was that supposed to be funny that's
just that's just mean
oh my God all right can we just throw
him he looks really cool just put him on
I mean my goodness that's a mean player
card he's still better than the
Charlotte Bobcats that went 10 and 72.
uh he is looking like a killer uh he is
a back from the dead it's like a UFC
fighter that loses three in a row and
then scores a flying knockout and takes
his shorts off of course I'm talking
about Derek Lewis the one and only black
beast he looks very similar to daily
those uh daily dose had a rough time in
the group Anna right he went uh oh and
three but he is back and he is ready for
Redemption uh and also he's coached by
uh Nemo apparently I did not know that
so
um we their game is going to get started
soon so let me talk about Jarvis his
opponent uh
Jarvis was a beast he came in having not
played any games in 17 years he's got
over 600 million views on this is all
the stuff about his career he's an
incredible person incredible content
creator three-time streamy award
commentary nominee incredible dude now
let's throw us back on the screen for a
second because we gotta talk about
Jarvis I commentated a few of his early
matches and uh this dude came out of
nowhere and he nearly beat Sea Dog he
beats Sea Dog and then was beating him
in their Blitz playoff and lost on time
and I don't know if you got a chance to
catch his match that he is crazy like
he's a sleeper to win
the whole uh consolation bracket and
he's going up against daily dose who's
got a fire under him who's got the
Matrix glasses I don't know what to
expect it's going to be some crazy stuff
I think it's going to be absolutely
amazing you're very right Jarvis he has
played so well and it feels like he's
improving also all throughout the turn I
mean it's becoming better and better and
better and uh he's playing right now
against daily dose who was part of the
group b which was the hardest group in
POG Champs in my opinion so I think
daily does even though he did lose all
of his matches he played some really
good chess I mean the chess that he
played it was really close on him
beating some of the participants so it's
definitely I think gonna be a very close
match now and I'm very excited to watch
it I'm I want to see if Jarvis is
wearing some cool sunglasses just like
daily doses or not I mean I would put
them on right now if I was him yeah
we're waiting for Jarvis to connect I
don't think he's actually uh on camera
just yet but yeah just like a reminder
of the Journey of the players daily dose
had literally literally got zero points
in the group so you look at that you go
huh he lost every match in the rapid but
it's not that simple like his match
against ghastly could have gone either
way all right he was very close to
leveling the score versus sapnap that
would have guaranteed him a point you
know he played virtual next then virtual
like was he 1200 was he 2100 was he 200
like nobody knew right so it was a tough
match for sure uh Jarvis meanwhile uh
has had like a very different journey I
mean he you didn't know what he was he
had a rating of zero and like no games
played at all and then it turns out that
he's like 900 level 800 level uh and he
was in a tough group so we see them on
camera
them absolutely just Jarvis for now uh
Anna but I'm pumped I don't know what to
expect
I think it's gonna be really fun I'm
just wondering you know last time daily
those played when he played against
virtual he didn't really know uh what
the game was for he didn't really know
that uh he was already going to the
constellation bracket so I'm wondering
if he actually knows that if he loses
now he's getting eliminated that is my
my biggest question that do the players
know that this match is is all in now I
mean the loser will be out of POG Champs
do the players know the format of the
event that is a wonderful question it
was a 50 success rate last match and we
also don't even know if squeaks knew the
format like you know we showed him the
bracket during the interview but maybe
if he had lost he would have been like
wait I'm eliminated so it's good it's
good nobody knows anything we're just
here to play chess and have fun uh in
the words of fusley so uh and uh it's uh
it's it's gonna be a wonderful time
um Jarvis has the white pieces in the
first game and after three matches
apparently has an ELO of 841 which is
monstrous so he's already looking like
the highest rated player in the
consolation bracket and Jarvis uh plays
E4 and that's about all I know and I
just know that daily dose plays the bird
which is F4 so yeah I've seen videos
playing a lot of the bird
um which is why virtual he decided to
play the cow because you know cow versus
the bird
um but yeah I'm very excited to see this
I mean Jarvis might be a favorite of the
constellation bracket but I think daily
does this up there too
I sorry I I went I went dead NPC there
for a second because we've just been
told I I like having private
conversations with production and the
chat doesn't know anything it's like so
funny I know I had that yesterday I know
how it feels it feels cool I I enjoy it
a lot
um the oh of course if you're just
joining us let's remind you what the
match format is that's important uh the
players are going to play two rapid
games against each other many of you
heard this many times just just bear
with us because you know if somebody
Pops in they don't know even know what's
going on right so they play two rapid
games of 10 minute and five second bonus
chess the winner of the mini match of
two games moves on to the semi-finals uh
and uh the loser does not not all of
them know that but those are the rules
uh and uh if it's tied one to one they
are going to play a blitz playoff uh
we've had a couple of those we had a
double overtime between sapnap and gasly
that was a lot of fun uh and I do
believe that games are about to get
underway uh move one is on the board and
Jarvis has played Pawn to E4 daily dose
in the boxer gloves ready I mean the
boxing hands E4 E5 just like in the
World Cup Knight to F3 and here we go
the philador defense from daily dose one
thing I like a lot about daily dose is
he says he's hyper competitive one thing
I don't like about daily dose is he
doesn't put himself in the best position
to succeed Anna like he plays a lot of
openings that have slight issues like
you know he played F6 against sapnap and
had a very kg position but with a lot of
weaknesses so chess players oftentimes
don't put themselves in good positions
to succeed because they don't follow the
basic principles like D4 right now is a
great move right it is a great move yeah
I mean I think he's trying to follow the
the principles but um but yeah you're
absolutely right and I do think that
this is totally fine now though I think
that yes his dark scored Bishop is going
to be a little bit locked in but at
least it's a pretty solid opening and
there we go we see Jarvis playing D4
which is a great move yeah and you see
daily dose likes to do this and he does
it a lot but you you cannot play chess
as an aspiring beginner and do your own
thing it's just not possible it's like
if you try to ride a bike a different
way than it was supposed to be written
you would fall like there is literally
no other way to ride a bike you have to
press the pedals in a certain direction
and hold on to the handlebars so he did
this also against sapnap and it worked
out about 20 30 moves down the line but
he's already at a massive disadvantage
because he has no space and even in the
game against sapnap he complained he
couldn't get his Bishop out but here he
is doing the same thing so wow G5 oh G5
you cannot say you're competitive but
not put yourself in a position to
succeed this like breaks my heart you
know what I mean like ah foreign
I do feel sad because I thought after he
got checkmated in six moves he might
start looking a little bit more into
King's safety but I suppose that's not
the case yet no the only thing he has
going for him is that beginners don't
really know how to exploit something
like this and they might even think oh
my God he's doing something he's taking
space this bishop is now a million
dollar piece and if you trade it off but
but just but just this right you know
yeah he's going all in though like do
you see it do you see his face right now
like he's going all in he decided that
he's gonna win but the problem is that
he needs to at least get that king
castle soon as well I get the Knight
I'll get the queen I'll go alongside
castles he's going a little bit too
early with this I feel like oh but he's
getting a big response out of Jarvis
which is you know fine the computer
doesn't like it because of take take and
G4 just shutting the door here and the
the next best move is like trying to
develop I mean the computer understands
that it is not equipped to attack and if
he takes there's going to be a blockade
uh and uh
again you you can say you're hyper
competitive but you have to give
yourself a you have to you have to do
things slightly the right way right
because we
what I will say and what I always say to
beginners is like if your position after
seven eight moves does not look like
some top level games
it's probably for a good reason right
and we have moves
yeah I mean I would say that I do like
the creativity but yeah the truth is
that a lot of times the creativity
doesn't really work
um in these sort of games but I'm hoping
right now that we see a little bit more
of Peace development that we see
alongside castles but I will say this I
think that for Jarvis this can be hard
to play against it's not easy to see a
full-on uh Battle of pieces in front of
your king it can get very very very
scary so maybe Jarvis will will get a
little bit intimidated by this yeah
already the best move for white is to go
back to try to trade the bishop
now it's all it's already turning around
and this very well could work out for a
daily dose uh in this particular game
but for a long-term weapon you can't do
stuff like this you're just not putting
yourself but you know you also could
play chess however you want they told
artists of the past that
by the way as Jarvis has made a move
that even equalizes the position they
used to tell artists of the past that
they can't do certain things or certain
techniques and they did them and became
famous so
um I actually think you're right and I
think Jarvis is in trouble
yeah no I actually think that daily dose
is gonna get the the good opening here
he's done his own thing but I think he's
gone into Jarvis head and I think Jarvis
is getting nervous so I actually really
really interestingly those in this game
yeah Jarvis is already like two moves
away from just being worse uh wow great
move I just drew an arrow there oh but
he's got to deal with that he's got to
slide over uh he unpinned himself which
means he can now move his Knight back
which is a huge huge deal
um
will you move it back like will he go
Knight H2 is a very difficult move to
see to just move it back to that square
it looks very passive there
yeah and by the way he gets his Queen
out of the way the problem for daily
dose is that he might go long but that
just walks right into White's attack so
because of the way that he's played this
opening he has massive long-term
problems he cannot Castle this way he
probably cannot castle that way either
the computer for black already wants to
play moves like Rook H7 which I don't
even know how to explain uh but the next
few moves will decide who's probably
going to win this game oh
I don't like that
creates an a very simple plan for black
though to just push the pawns and see
what happens
right exactly
um but and G4 is coming for sure just
don't play H4 because you're not trying
to attack on the light squares trying to
uh yeah there you go there we go that's
the best move will Jarvis find this
Queen F5
Queen if I could get scared the queen T6
and that King might start to see the
consequences of uh being without all its
Pawns
wow wow well spotted and daily dose does
play too quickly like he might play
Knight H6 virtually instantly and lose
H5 Queen G6 just still comes in he's
gonna see this and just do this right
away and it could backfire this is a
huge problem and he's attacking on the
light squares which have been weakened
by the first of us four moves for black
right so are you hearing Jarvis do we
have him open mic'd I think so I think
I'm hearing some boys I think it's
Jarvis
I think we have an open mic on Jarvis
trying to
get his thoughts of which you're mostly
just hmm
hmm it's just fair enough that's how I
sound when I'm playing chess too
no it's not I've been to Anna kramling
streams no no it's not that is not you
do not sit there making thinking noises
okay now that I'm streaming not when I'm
streaming but if I'm just playing for
myself and I'm concentrating on making
thinking noises at tournaments like in
the silence you just no
no no but in my living room when I'm
playing chess you know I'm like what are
you playing in your living room none of
these
oh
that that's that's fair that's fair
that's fair that's fair um Levy you
missed one thing that once you were away
and that was that one daily that was
playing virtual he actually resigned in
a in an equal position because he
thought that he was completely lost and
I'm very scared that he is going to see
his attack fail get really upset and
then you know somehow like tilt and
resign or something like that because
what happened last time you mean daily
doses
right there what is it any of those were
signed against virtual yeah in an equal
position because he thought he was lost
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I I I I think he
did that against sapnap as well and it's
weird because
uh but I feel for him like he he
exhibits this kind of thing where he's
super competitive what if I did that but
oh he's just oh no the Knight protects
it
why if I do that I'm so confused he's
just turned up I don't know did we just
be quiet when he speaks is he like God
here
just hearing his voice
I thought it was like schizo like I just
kept hearing voices
or not let me I'm not gonna lie oh my
goodness I'm so confused I I just kept I
was like is that Anna like his eyes okay
he's not that I know he's still talking
all right you know what all right I
guess he's just part of the commentary
now I guess he's just part of that his
daily dose is not talking so I you know
um
oh my goodness hi Jarvis how you doing
man can you hear me
I hope not
Oh I thought that was his voice saying I
hope not
hey Queen G6
checks it's like getting scary
yeah yeah daily dose is gonna have to
find the Gap good move Queen F7 now the
best move for for white here is to throw
in another check that's unfindable at
this level just forcing the king to
uh
to go and then stopping the knights
escape and then B4 is the there's no way
Bishop B5 I mean the bishop B5 would be
a crazy move Bishop if I would be crazy
but I think Jarvis can see it I feel
like he knows that there's something
going on in this position otherwise it
would go Queen takes F7 immediately I
think he knows that there are some
tactics with the king in the middle I
okay 97 97 traps the queen oh my God
Anna it's what you said you said this
could happen
did I
yes you said oh oh you said Queen F5 was
scary for black
but it's also no I said it I
I knew it I was sure of it yes oh 97
Knight H oh and it's on the board
oh
wow that is amazing
Mighty Seven
see and this is the problem because now
daily dose is gonna play this nonsense
again and he's gonna think he won
because of this he did not wear you know
what whatever he understands chess
better than me I gotta have I gotta have
a talk with daily dose super nice guy
but so stubborn
he just does what he wants people is
watching this for him Levy it's working
for him it's not working for him because
of him it's working for him because his
opponents aren't punishing it like
Jarvis was winning right he was winning
and he just couldn't capitalize now the
queen of strapped he
you know daily does got to make his own
opening this is the daily dose of
Internet opening right here this is the
it's right here just
daily dose of Chess daily dose of chest
daily dose of Chess exactly that was
actually a channel uh that that's a cool
guy he's a edits a lot of stuff for me
for others daily dose of Chess used to
upload a lot of cool compilations anyway
Knight to E7 attacks F5 and
um
what about Bishop B5 check now maybe
Jarvis will play it in a desperate
attempt but obviously I mean it doesn't
really do much I guess either the king
can move to a fate or oh
[Applause]
you can
why does he do that why does he play so
fast where's he to rush to does he have
business meetings he moves so he made
that move in one second
he's hanging all his pieces
Anna he he constantly puts himself in
situations to win and then look I know
but then he just doesn't
ah they had it just night takes but the
nights don't move backwards like us but
he I mean he he built the house and
right before laying the last brick he
just drove a tractor through it like he
he did everything he did everything
right and then oh my goodness why you
know how fast he played Queen E6 2.5
seconds 2.5 seconds on this move daily
goes just slowed down a little bit seven
minutes he has seven minutes now he's
getting the Rook out of the open file my
only Last Hope here was for the Rooks to
double up get a pawn to G3 and then
somehow track me but not even that dream
is gone this is a great move Knight D5
he's gonna trade this night off and this
Pawn is a passer once white activates
the bishop in this it's just what Anna
said the only chance that you have is to
take the open file and weave what is
called a checkmating net so the king
cannot Escape off the back rank
oh wow
I can't believe it I I was so sure that
daily those had it there
he yeah I mean he just rushed he
he didn't even realize he trapped the
queen I wonder if Jarvis realized like I
wonder
I wonder if Jarvis realized and see now
daily dose is frustrated right you see
it there and and I feel for him but like
the the only way to prevent yourself
from being frustrated is to break your
bad habits right like that's the point
E7 is a great move by the way yeah and
uh but but now now is a key moment Anna
will Jarvis find a way through or is he
gonna get tangled in this web of pieces
It's Not Over
I feel like he might play Bishop B5
which is a pretty natural move kind of
looking at the Rock and I feel like that
move would be pretty good obviously it
doesn't win on the spot I guess the
Knight can retreat but Bishop B5 looks
pretty good or otherwise I guess he
might want to move his Knight on D5
because then The Rook on G8 is hanging
C6 is a fork though no
oh
yeah you're right you're right okay well
Jarvis might play it and put into those
fights here I was like wait a minute are
you are you predicting a pop Champion
with an engine okay I'm looking at this
just like the players are okay lovey I'm
looking at this just like them and I
missed it me too but I saw the fork I
mean okay well I wanted to ignore it but
I didn't I didn't know I thought you
were predicting that by the way that's a
great move Bishop to E3 Anna you were
predicting this is playing better than
me all right I give up I give up you
were predicting the move that's what you
were predicting Bishop B5 oh God
predicting Bishop B5 exactly oh does he
see does he see do both first of all do
either of them see right because
he missed it last time but now it's the
only thing that could be taken
um you must see it now I feel like both
people must see it at this moment in
time there's a great idea here to sack
the rook and play Bishop to D3 and the
Knight can't actually move anywhere
that's not findable at this level
the actual oh you know what's a tragedy
if you take the Rook the Knight takes
and you get forked like yeah the best
you just leave it there yeah you
actually have to leave it there like the
best move for black is not to take this
because then there's this
and then
oh my God this is so tragic for daily
dose
yeah because I was wondering if
something like Rook E6 would be played
if the Rook would be moved I mean The
Rook has
no it's not King D7 and then it's
uh yeah
this can take this now oh Jarvis missed
it
like now now would be a good time to
have audio what's he saying
hello
okay
but no no he's not success players hate
themselves he's not playing bad he just
made one mistake in 26 moves
The Rook is hanging right now by the way
like he could take the Rook at this very
moment yeah yeah he could take it it's
not over and then bring oh he's found it
now Knight takes is the best move oh
wow
oh look at the oh Knight F6 don't try no
wait no why are you trading when you're
losing oh my God I know what's happening
no don't trade Maybe
they're both playing too fast oh but
Jarvis has two minutes that makes sense
uh Anna this is about to get fast-paced
because I they're both going to speed up
so it's a completely winning end game
now because daily dose is up two pawns
um but he has to take the open file he
has to push his King and his pawns
together that is how you win this and
then you overwhelm white you trade
pieces down you win an end game by
promoting um he might get mated his King
is completely on the back rank does he
know to get his King off the back rank
is another question
I was gonna say that I was gonna say
that I'm calling Rook F1 and then if
daily does would move his Knight to some
square that uh well the route where the
reconstopian then Rook f8 would be a
background Checkmate so that would be
right now if I was Jarvis that is what I
would play but daily does is stopping it
immediately look at that even pudding
lights Square yeah which is preventing
sort of checks that's amazing stuff uh
he might bring his King next this is an
excellent move and now Rook F6 just Rook
F6 that's all you can do just bother
bother bother uh this brick wall of
Pawns is too good uh excellent move now
now daily dose could get his Knight
trapped like Bishop F2 or Bishop G5 and
the Knight is stuck
absolutely the Knight has to move either
to E7 or fully go to F4 but that just
loses a pawn and they'll lose the G4
Pawn as well most probably so there's
Knight F4 take take Rook takes Ponte G
oh I I don't like retreating to the back
rank just don't go here a lot of people
forget this a piece just moved from a
square it still defends it don't go Rook
G6 pointless movement this is pointless
movement what am I doing
it no I can't do that why is he so
negative stop the negative self-talk no
he needs to be
[Applause]
why so fast
what is the point of all of this
movement that I'm doing
okay okay
I gotta breathe I gotta breathe
um the only way for Jarvis to save his
Rook is to move his Bishop Anna the only
way otherwise it's completely stuck
does he know that
oh there's a fork and a fork he's gotta
take pork lots of forks he's gotta take
but then we're gonna see a couple past
pawns I mean c takes okay I would take
with the other one you want to have the
two connected past pawns the way that
that he did it you have this and uh now
the kings are coming but Anna does he
know
yeah if the King goes here this king is
going to come here and it's game over
yeah I mean it's very natural to just
bring the king up the board uh there's
no way he's going anywhere else with the
king so I'm sure he's just gonna bring
up the king I think this even if if I'm
games are typically harder at this level
I think our daily dose is gonna he's got
this here he's got this he's gonna bring
up the king and the g Pawn is gonna win
somehow
Rook G5
I I guess he's trying to get in like
this this is this is a relatively
straightforward one
um yeah D5 is a nice move just making
progress
uh
and yeah now here we go but now now here
comes King E4 the only way that black
loses this game is by getting hit with a
rook skewer and obviously the only way
black doesn't win this game is with a
stalemate which is possible like the
king is absolutely
but now look at that oh look at now c4
and two pass pawns very strong play by
daily those here very strong play now
those pawns Roll by themselves pretty
much yup D3 King D4 C3 just gonna March
him down like the Terminator again
opportunity for a stalemate he is
white dusting off his hands
he's he's a he's like he's talking trash
I don't know if the whole game deserves
a trash talk but oh
you cannot script the stuff oh my God
and you know what the craziest part is
he still might be winning because C3
King E3 I know he's not winning on the
eval bar Anna but the pawns are are
there oh my God he's out of his chair
I hope it doesn't resign I hope he does
not tilt and resign he needs to keep
going here now
that is so crazy because we know him as
the cool calming voice of internet video
compilations
but this man ain't cool and calm right
now there might be holes in that room I
mean there might be stuff might be out
the window I don't know if he's still in
Norway he gonna get a cleaning fee on
the Airbnb I mean my goodness he needs
to reset that is crazy that is
absolutely crazy right as he did the
hand wipe
wow I mean this was it almost looked
scripted how good this was he's back now
though and I just hope he has five
minutes he's got a lot of time on the
clock he just really needs to get
through this mistake and still try to
win push the pawn push the king push
everything you have
and don't resign
wow that is
unbelievable what a moment
do we have volume on him I kind of want
to hear what he's saying I I don't know
I don't
totally saying all sorts of stuff
hmm
oh my goodness but but and I'm telling
you this game is not over because no no
to win this white needs to bring the
king like to these squares oh just as
long as it doesn't make any three like
like oh yeah like this is not over Anna
this is not over King here this is not
over King here take here always lost it
lost at the pawn and then C2 is game
over oh my God you have to go no C2
daily doses back to winning
the only chance Anna the only chance
King B3 Rook F3 and somehow he hangs his
pawns unbelievable I called it C2 C2
come on here we go it's gonna be a queen
it's queening
the only plot twist remaining is if he
will still stalemate because he plays
too fast
okay he's taking the Pawns
he's gonna make another queen I mean he
cannot he knows the ladder chalk mate I
can't I don't think
there's no way there's a stone made here
Jarvis had to get rid of his Pawn
there's no way to stalemate uh there's
gonna be a ladder I think he's coming
here
yeah and and that's just gonna be game
over Queen takes and then he's gonna do
it yeah Queen takes and
It's Over Now The trackmates oh my God
it's over wow
who wins the game
daily dose with multiple walk-offs
we have seen more of this dresser and
wall in this vague place that he is than
we have of him
and after one game of one of the most
chaotic matches I have ever seen it is
one to nothing daily dose of internet
and it's one to nothing of our like
local uh meditating tea like I mean we
we're gonna all need some chamomile tea
after that because that was
a lot of words Levy I don't even know
what to say my heart it hasn't pumped
like this like ever like I have not
experienced this before this was
absolutely insane the plot twist one
thought will never happen happen in this
game and I don't even think they did
those beliefs that he won the game like
yeah this is incredible and Jarvis
looked so calm throughout the whole game
I was I I honestly like I I feel as
though nothing uh I mean none of them
thought that they were going to win that
game at any point Jarvis was so negative
throughout the game even though he was
doing super well and then uh and then
and then oh my goodness that was um wow
that was that was Sensational and daily
dose
to falling out of his chair
on multiple occasions right after he
dusted his hands off and then hung his
rook in one move
but you know the funny thing Latvia is
that in this match they were like Polar
Opposites like Jarvis was being very
negative about his moves but then dated
those he was the opposite he was very
confident and then it just clashed I
mean then we just had a mix of chaos but
that's how it all started that that is
how it all started uh what what an
absolutely ridiculous back and forth
battle
and yeah Jarvis cool calm and collected
he's uh
he he is a uh he he's he I mean he's
cool as a cucumber and he doesn't give
himself enough credit
no he should have gave himself more
credit he played a really good game
um but it was just at the very end he
had it all the way until the end you
know if he just brought the king back
but
it was tough it was uh it was tough it
was tough and and that's life I mean
that's how it goes you know like I had a
feeling when he lost the Rook it was not
over two connected past pawns you had
mentioned it uh it's uh
it's
what they roll by themselves yeah it is
it is wild
um we have game number two
I wish they could play a best of four
uh F4 there it is now did Jarvis study
the Gambit that sapnap played that would
be gangster he did not he plays
he plays this and and and and yeah daily
those not
discouraged by the Gambit that sapnap
played
no no not at all I mean they let those
place this this opening pretty much
every game I've only seen playing the
bird I don't really know how it started
because it's typically not the first
opening you learn in chess but he loves
the bird and I'm sure Jarvis has
prepared this because it's literally
pretty much the only thing that daily
does plays but now I have this little
formation of Pawns in the center and it
does look pretty solid but I like here
that Jarvis can always have his Knight
going to E4 there's no Pawn that will
okay I thought he was gonna take with
the pawn and then everything that I said
just would not matter but he took with
the queen and it still applies yeah now
it's kind of like a stone wall uh this
looks good for white but you aren't
really supposed to trade your light
squared Bishop so easily just as long as
you plug this so Knight D2 uh then
Knight E5 and
again I I'm I'm describing what you're
supposed to do uh but you know daily
dose is uh is his own man and he uh he
he will do whatever he wants maybe he'll
play G4 G5 but you're supposed to stop
this put this here Rook F3 Rook H3 and
Checkmate but yeah
because the
he does what he wants so we'll see we'll
see what his next move is going to be I
have absolutely no predictions
whatsoever but I do know what you are
supposed to do in the position okay not
bad
three very solid solid chest this is
the previous game I feel like soon
to see that
it's bias you know bringing up all his
pieces going full on aggressive towards
the king but maybe that was just his
prep for game number one with the black
pieces maybe now he's just going for the
draw
he did in fact play the move before
um you you are supposed to go in this
direction oh okay we are we're just
playing over here now B5 is going to
push the Knight back uh and um I just it
just hit me why he plays the way he
plays with black is because he kind of
does the same thing with white
yeah it's always the same kind of
information yeah it's much worse with
black because
you fall behind in development and you
have no space but it's basically the
same thing what it's fine
it's fine I mean now Jarvis doesn't have
a lot of space the night went back he's
gonna have to uh develop his Knight
going Knight D7 Knight B6 maybe but this
I feel like can be very annoying to play
um against this black because you don't
really have any break you can't go E5
you don't really have any clear plan
here I feel like it's black can be very
difficult to know sometimes what to do
and now Bishop A3 just training that bad
Bishop for for blacks pretty good dark
squared Bishop absolutely although at
this level I think it was mostly like
can I go here it's a fair trade uh it
must be a good move but yes exactly like
that's in the Stonewall you have a
problem bishop and uh the problem Bishop
is the dark screen Bishop so probably we
will get this or queen B5 that's fine
now this Pawn is hanging in uh daily
dose has the amount of time that he
started with so he is very confident
this game
I I think it's always very confident um
and I think actually that in many of
these games it is really good to be
confident you kind of need it in some of
these games I think
he's too confident but oh in this case
it's going to pay off last game he was
also very confident and that that
that didn't work out and then it did
work out and then it didn't work out and
and yeah now Queen takes B7 is a clean
free pawn it could get worse very
quickly because the Knight defends the
bishop which is being attacked I can't
draw arrows which is being attacked by
that bishop and then if the Knight moves
and white takes the bishop then he might
attacks the queen in the rook and then
you're gonna take the rook and then we
do a whole little could get ugly very
quickly you know Queen takes B7 if
Jarvis is not careful it could get ugly
very quickly yes although I am confused
what daily dose is thinking about
because I thought this entire plan was
designed to take this Pawn but he he
surprises me sometimes so she has a box
full of surprises you know but that's
what brings to excitement and you'll
never know what the surprise is because
he's wearing sunglasses that make us not
be able to see his eyes
yeah they're they're they're very very
cool sunglasses and by the way after 13
moves of both sides the accuracy is 94
to 92 percent uh not after that move but
it's 93 to 92 percent
uh
that's a very high accuracy to be honest
and I think okay didn't take the pawn in
B7 which he probably should have but
he's developing his Knight which is not
a bad movie either he had to develop it
at some point and then maybe he'll bring
in the Rooks maybe Rook off B1 and just
get a big battery on that B file
yes best thing now for black is to just
get rid of this bishop and then move the
queen and white could blunder The Rook I
mean maybe maybe not this is the this is
of course one of the higher rated
matchups of the constellation bracket
now Queen E7 is a nice move or queen D6
both attacking The Rook
yeah he should try it I Like Queenie
Sami because then the pawn and B7 is not
hanging anymore but sometimes taking the
pawn on B7 can also lead to your queen
being trapped so he could also try to
set up Queen D6 and then hope that uh
daily dose takes the pawn on B7
is
there it is Queen C7 now maybe Rook B3
or maybe a pawn move or it's a very
tense game
it is a very tense game but the queen
goes back okay uh
but that's
a trip to the beefal with a very
short-lived trip
agreed B7 is hanging in some lines but
now we're not gonna that we need a new
plan and I I'm assuming his plan is to
go here I I'm guessing
now it doesn't quite work because black
can play H6 but then you could maybe
attack but I have learned over time the
daily dose is not to be predicted and
you just sort of let him lead the way
and then you talk about it that's that's
sort of how you Knight G4 okay wow so
now Knight G5 will do everything daily
does wanted it to do which is to thread
and check of it in one I feel like oh
he's going H3 first maybe he's gonna go
G4 and he's gonna start an attack over
there I really hope not uh but but yes
one of the problems with moving the
Knight here is
you need to be ready for just getting
kicked out so beginners y'all should
stop just moving your Knights to the
edges because if your opponent can just
play H3 like it doesn't actually do you
any favors Anna predicts G4
yeah honestly I think G4 is going to
happen I mean I feel like it's like 70
30 odds that it's G4 or another move
I still think he'll play Knight G5 but
but like I said I mean he could continue
here he could push upon he has like 10
moves in this position that maintain the
evaluation so I I really have no he
could play a five which is a move
I could be pretty good at five I mean
kind of just breaking that pawn chain
but I still think G4 I think is looking
at G4 and it feels oh okay I take that
back wow he is looking at the opposite
side he wants to go back to the B file
which is weird because he he literally
just left the B file oh The Rook is
hanging oh my goodness oh sneaky oh he
will try to take the pawn maybe and then
the Rook will hang
yeah but but this move gets out of that
danger and now there's two things
attacking that pawn and that pawn is
almost not guardable so this is very
very very tricky
high risk High reward move I feel like
Queen D6 but I think it's good that
Jarvis is
going for the tricks why did he yeah he
seemed very upset was that what was that
reaction did he almost blunder The Rook
is that what happened like did he is he
just beside himself because
why is he upset what is going on why is
he shaking his head is he shaking his
head because he almost went here and
hung The Rook we don't actually know
we have no idea why but the position
still seems fine he hasn't there we go
he played the best move and I like
somebody in the chat said he's emoting
just just did like one of his like seven
emotes and he's just a little oh my god
um wow
well all right that's a fantastic move
though I mean that was the best move in
the position he has everything under
control and this time he's actually been
thinking a little bit more look at that
seven and a half minutes we're not
seeing a 10 minute game where he still
has like the starting time now he's
taking a sweet time to think about some
good moves
exactly right uh a very natural move by
black after you realize that defending
this with the pawn is hopeless is to
defend it with the Knight and that move
is regarded very poorly by the computer
because it gets in the way of the Rooks
and for the temporary uh pleasure of not
losing this Pawn you just begin to get
steamrolled and white very quickly
activates all of their pieces at night
here and Knight here and this is just
very very bad so
I still think it might be played because
it's so natural
but long term it causes some prop and
there it is there it is there it is he
really wanted to keep the pawn and I
understand this and the question is is
that the best practical move to just not
let daily those come in with the Rooks
is it
uh it's definitely the best move for
this level because neither one of them
knows that it's plus 1.5 due to
positional advantage of white having
more space and using Pawn breaks to get
into the position uh like C4 is the
critical move if white plays C4 he's in
great shape but Knight E5 is good and
all these different moves are good but
white is only better because of the
space advantage and the pressure on the
B Pawn so
I still think Levy that we're gonna see
G4 soon I'm still calling for G4 I feel
like he's gonna bring up his Knight to
E5 he's gonna go G4 and he's gonna try
to take as much space as possible on the
king side you don't think so
I don't think so I I have a feeling he
is a reformed man
I have a feeling the last game taught
him not to be too arrogant he's gonna
focus on one side of the board he's not
going to open up too many problems this
is his Redemption Arc he's a positional
chess player beautiful move Knight to E5
applying the pressure turning the screw
very nice now he's not playing no G4 G4
G5 is amateur stuff and daily dose is no
amateur
no he is no amateur but G4 G5 does look
like it's pressuring the king side quite
a lot whilst the queen and the Rooks are
disconnected I mean I don't know I'm
calling for it I know it's not not good
but I I think it might happen Chad do
you think he's gonna play that too what
are you thinking chat
no chance
I don't think he's playing G4 the
problem is not what he's playing the pro
the problem is what is Jarvis playing I
mean that that is really the struggle
here
I
have daily dose is a positional
Grandmaster oh my God he's using a pawn
break to get peace activity and if his
opponent doesn't take he just plays C5
and suddenly the C Pawn is no longer an
a weakness it's an asset taking space
away C5 March him down eat the pawns eat
the pawns and go
and the pawn is pinned I mean C5 C6 Pawn
cannot take because then The Rook is
hanging yup and it's on the board oh my
goodness the the Cobra is tightening its
grip this is crazy stuff and soon G4
could become useful to remove the knight
from the defense of the Rook so now you
like
Jimmy now you're pricing my move G4 I I
I I you know uh it was good in in
certain moments uh but uh bad in other
moments
G4 was there wasn't anything
super wrong with it but Knight D7 would
be the move that I would play now Knight
D7 actually loses to Queen B5 but at
that level that's very hard to spot uh
for sure it forces like if if you get
this trade it helps a lot but white
should still go here and
um
so far this is a master class and how to
handle a locked position and focus on
one side of the board this is like
expert stuff
honestly I'm intrigued to see the
accuracy from daily dose because this
game he's played so well by far his best
game of the tournament I think super
amazing game so far I don't want to jinx
it I I don't want him to blunder it Rook
somehow uh later on in the game but
great game so far
whether Rook A8 like Jarvis just and
again this is all the result of the yup
now why
you want to do
this overreacts and now Rook A6 is just
winning a pawn Anna
Pun It's
that's totally fine
suspect the king could just walk up The
Border's position is so good
he wanted to get all his pieces in the
attacks I mean this man is a Madman
Queen A6 is winning a pawn
just just a completely free Pawn he can
just take it
okay misses it now now black could start
getting out of there
I do have a little bit worried about
that King on F2 I mean it was just so
nice and safe on June there was no
reason for it to be moved up oh this is
not overnight you could accidentally
take Fork lose this pawn and suddenly
Black's Queen is getting in and you
really regret moving the king here I
mean 94 after that uh that would be so
incredibly clutch daily dose has one
final moment if he takes
oh no the Knight can go to B4 now oh no
there's a block over there
oh God and and this king is wide open I
don't know why this man brought this
King out here uh that King could get hit
with a million different flying objects
it's crazy oh god wow it was the most
unexpected move as well you know I
thought he was using all of his other
pieces but no he he wanted to use the
king as well like who said they
so that was losing after Rook here but
it's still not over
it's still not over and it's totally
losable for example Rook B7 Queen C8
Rook F7 Knight E5 and The Rook loses a
guard
can you not just take the pawn on e4
which is an easier move and just be much
better
uh yes I did not see that
but neither did he no
okay he looks pretty good I mean Rook B6
is going for the A6 Pawn now again he
could take it earlier but now he's going
for it again but a lot of pawns are
hanging here yeah
I did not see Queen E4 that's crazy uh
but but you know what if I didn't see it
and and like you didn't see the forecast
game you know what they did it they
maybe were in the clear
um he's gotta go here night before is
still the best move to defend this and
disconnect these pieces and then F6 is
the key if he gets F6 removing the
Knight rotates his Queen it's anybody's
game oh but this is stressful he's taken
now Fe gotta be the best move gotta take
toward the center don't remove the
defense over here no no I'm really
important and he does it even if the
king is opening up and yeah F6 is is the
shot but you know what the thing is that
people tell you never play F6 so it he
Jarvis could have it in grade in his
brain no no
it's over
no he just he's just miscal he just
miscounted oh no oh it's over
it's also track me it's also a track
meet
daily dose brushes his shoulders off
dude he is going full heel I mean he is
fist pumping 2-0 daily dose take I mean
my God who is this guy he he's becoming
the villain of pogchamps
I mean this is incredible also because
he did end up in the bracket side he
finished with zero points but now he's
just coming for the Redemption look at
that wow 2-0 game is over
consolation quarterfinals are second
match daily dose with a very convincing
second game uh the first game was uh was
chaos Unleashed but he had control of a
majority of the game that was that that
was a that was a very very fun round uh
we're gonna try to get some player
interviews Jarvis is great on the mic so
you know we we'll see if we have the
time uh and uh
what more could I say that was a
tremendous amount of fun shall we take a
look at the bracket uh let's do it two
quarterfinal
matchups done
squeaks moving on to the semi's daily
dose as well squeaks awaits the winner
of virtual versus psychuno and daily
dose of Internet awaits the winner of uh
cutie Cinderella and Ginny and I this is
a small correction from earlier because
a b do not play a B so a b play like CD
and and so on that's how it works we mix
everybody so there's a small correction
uh these two players will not play each
other they're still awaiting opponents
that was a lot of fun Anna uh maybe
maybe not for Jarvis but um on the other
side of things we have daily dose of
internet and uh he was Victorious we are
going to get him for an interview we're
gonna ask him hard-hitting questions
such as why did you put on sunglasses
why did you become the villain of the
event and uh did it hurt when you fell
out of the chair don't go anywhere an
interview with dailydose of Internet on
the other side of the short break
[Music]
all the way
foreign
and welcome to Lifetime repair tours
wonderful
the so-called Latin Gambit is horrible
F5
Knight takes E5 this is not how chess
has played he played too many moves with
pawns and the Queen and didn't develop
his light pieces
in this Knight E4 this is a very
important trick to remember many people
fall for it actually Knight to B5
brilliant ID a b and queen G7 and after
Cafe Bishop H6 Queen C5 and F3 and
surprisingly clean F2 is almost
Checkmate but it's not
wants to be solid we go for the
aggressive for the kill if your opponent
wants us to go for the kill we play
Simple chess and just use the fact that
we have more space in the center
clear-cut plants and nothing to worry
about
[Music]
thank you
let's go
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
fox Champs 5. we've just been watching
this crazy matchup between daily dose of
internet and Jarvis and then we see that
we that's all we get we just get the
walk off the empty room oh he's back and
I think we're gonna get the second
reaction there we go look at that the
peace sign and we're lucky enough to be
joined by Mr go and dust your shoulders
up brush your shoulders off with the JC
with Jay-Z say sunglasses daily dose
welcome to the show congrats on your
first win uh and uh how does it feel how
you feeling right now talk to us about
the whole thing what are we seeing here
is this a rejuvenated daily dose of
internet or you know here's the
situation people think I'm wearing these
sunglasses because I want to look cool
no I wore them because I didn't want
people to see me crying when I lose
here's the other thing I can die with
style
without wait that was it I thought that
there was more
yeah I'm gonna you know go to my go to
my own funeral I want to at least look
pretty cool you know
they look great on you they look really
good on you to be honest gotta say that
yeah I I thought it was to psych out
your opponents I didn't realize it was
it was for the other stuff yeah well
here's the thing I heard uh I'm not
Norwegian but the Norwegians told me
that if I buy these sunglasses I
officially become uh I get Norwegian
citizens I'm I'm officially a Norwegian
that's what I was told
that also means you're a member of the
EU you could now you could become a
Schengen citizen right like you can just
go anywhere
yeah and you would become amazing at
chess because Norwegians are so good at
chess
true true you know here's the thing um
that first game uh where I screwed up at
The Rook there that was a misclick that
was a hundred percent a misclick i i
that's why I was so mad I I just put
like my work too far
yeah yeah we uh we we we we did realize
that uh
that that had occurred uh also the chat
is telling me that Norway is not in the
European what it's not Lobby I I didn't
know if I wanted to break it to you but
you seemed so happy about it so I just
let it go what
why is Norway not in is Sweden yeah yeah
what
I did not know that why are they not
okay whatever I'm not even gonna get
into that right now I I learned
something today uh yeah yeah daily dose
that that second game though man you
played it like 92 you got the exact
setup good yes you got the setup you
wanted you you squeezed him like a snake
squeezes its victims I mean it was it
was a crazy crazy game like what that
was that was a wild wild performance and
did we just not get to see the side of
you because because of the group you
were in that's what we've been
discussing yeah the group I was in was
stacked like everyone is so good and I I
played well against everyone
um and like I kept it close against
everyone and I made like two dumb
mistakes early on so like I feel like I
should be a lot better than I actually
am but whatever
can I just say daily those I agree with
you your group was so good it was by far
the hardest group and you know I'm sorry
that you got put in the hardest group
because you were playing very well in
all of the games
um so it's unfortunately that I'm
fortunate that you're a put there
yeah yeah do you think uh that after
this that you're gonna be like the
winner of the consolation bracket like
do you see yourself winning the whole
thing
I don't know I don't know uh because uh
who who did I play last time I played um
uh I don't know who I played last time
but um I think he's gonna beat me
um because of the w
oh virtual virtual yeah yeah yeah
well here's the good news your next
opponent is either cutie Cinderella or
or Ginny uh do you do you know either of
them I you know you were at the streamer
Awards organized by cutie like do you
have a Scouting Report who would you
rather play uh and why
I I'm just happy to be there I don't
really care I'm just happy to be there
um I the fact that I actually won a game
I thought I was gonna go with this whole
like tournament without winning a single
game and I but I'm just happy I won and
it's so crazy because when I won that
when I won that game I said you won I
was like whoa that actually happened
um listen winning a game it it builds
confidence it's it's addicting uh I was
comparing you to a fighter that had
three setbacks and people think oh like
he's not gonna win and then you come
back rejuvenated super super dominant
performance against probably one of the
best players in the consolation bracket
like he was really really good and he
was resilient in these games and the
good news for you is that if you win
your next match you probably
guarantee a rematch and you could
literally 1v1 IRL virtual because that's
what's going to happen in L.A does that
excite you like is that you know you you
just punch him if you want I don't know
if you're ready no don't punch him
I've never thrown a punch in my life
so I don't know well chess boxing you
know it I mean we that we could always
arrange that in any case it will be an
IR it will be a 1v1 IRL I'm just trying
to you know be a chess fight promoter if
you will I'm looking forward to your
Redemption art because I knew I I knew
you were not the performance in the
group I'm very excited for you and today
was a really really good example of that
yeah thank you did you like my my
ramming speed set up there I had the
queen and the Rook go and I thought I
was just gonna ramps right through there
so
I don't know I don't know what to call
it I call it ramming speed I don't know
uh you could call it whatever you want I
mean it's called a battery but you were
it doesn't matter multiple multiple
times Anna and I would say oh like this
is an idea and then you know but it's a
little for this level it's a little too
hard then you would play it and we'd be
like oh
so very well done that second game was
like a 92 accuracy I mean it was amazing
it really was nice to ask you
yeah what no sorry go on I was just
gonna ask you the one meal me and Lavi
didn't understand it was the only move
in the whole two matches that we didn't
understand King F2 what were you trying
to do with the King
I'm not smart enough to know what that
means I'm sorry
oh also
not because I thought he was gonna try
and bring his Knight down and so I
wanted to have another piece there that
could potentially take out the night
um because if he like I didn't know
where he was gonna play that night so it
should I just thought it'd be good and
healthy to bring that King up
okay okay awesome yeah you
option bracket should be terrified of
playing you
this amazing good job on this match
appreciate it great stuff we will see
you in a couple of days uh once we
determine who your opponent is going to
be congrats on the on on the big win and
please come back in the sunglasses yes
please sounds good they're amazing
amazing all right thank you
see you see you bye
that's
that was a very very fun match Anna
we've got now two of our four
semi-finalists in the constellation
bracket there up on your screen and I
was going to sign off that interview by
saying that was your daily dose of
internet but I was too embarrassed
because he was still on the call with us
uh but that was in fact your daily dose
of Internet
uh Anna we're gonna take a short break
and then we've got one last matchup of
the day we've played a couple of matches
in the consolation bracket now it's time
for the champions of POG Champs five to
go to battle and we will be kicking it
off with Gastly the winner of Group B
the group of death versus Frank
the runner-up of group a but everybody's
favorite Tick Tock chest sensation don't
go anywhere pogchamps 5 will resume with
the championship bracket in just a few
minutes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I do love chess since we're winning boys
why don't we celebrate with a glass of
wine nine o'clock somewhere in the world
am I right
[Music]
oh boom
that was amazing I loved that yeah play
with our emotions just for a second
wow yes let's go
[Music]
yes he's garbage at chess it needs to
uninstall forever I will pick you up in
real life we're gonna allow him to
embarrass production like this dude
you're not serious can't wait to see you
Tyler
welcome back everyone to coverage of
punk Champs five it is time now for our
main event of the evening morning
afternoon wherever we are uh it's uh
it's going to be ghastly versus Frank it
has been a great day so far with some
very very fun moments and we are very
excited uh to Showcase two awesome
talents from the championship bracket
Anna how how much of a how much do you
know about these players like what have
you uh
what have you I know that I know that
ghastly is just better than his rating
that's all I know about Kelsey and then
Frank well I mean everyone knows Frank
but I think few people know Frank as
good as you do Levy you've been coaching
Frank quite a bit I I have I'm sort of
like uh you know I'm a distant uh Guru
giving advice just a quick reminder on
all that that was that that was the
championship bracket it doesn't matter
there's no matchups done yet we'll take
a look at it later when the matchup is
finished I um I I do know Frank well and
uh he I think today the big question is
going to be Frank's cheekiness and
explosiveness versus an experience
because he has played a lot of games
versus gastly's uh maturity like he he
he has been a grinder and uh we see him
there that that that
doesn't necessarily demonstrate
demonstrate his maturity but that's a
celebration there
um but he is able to sit and there's a
cartwheel that that right there that's
that's
they did not choose a clip that
supplemented my words but they chose the
clip before I said anything you know
this clip has been there so I probably
should have just
that was that's my fault that's the
commentator's curse right there uh wow
it is still going and he he is on the
ground there uh he he
um he's an American DJ and producer he's
played at many many festivals he's
played nearly uh 2000 games I think at
this point on chess.com uh and uh I
thought they would remove that last
bullet point when I asked it but you
know what it's fine I'm just I'm just
kidding he has a great coach and that is
why he was the winner of the group of
death
uh he actually beat uh both of our
students you know I I I considered
sapnap a protege and uh you considered
virtual and Gastly was the one that went
up top and and there he is and did he
change his hair color since last night
he did he does not look the way he did
the other day did he have brown hair
dark brown hair did he go blonde yeah
wow a new look there you go life of a
producer and a DJ that's what happens
one day you wake up and you got cool and
light air and it's looking good and um
he put out a tweet your boy just won
three consecutive chess matches in a row
in the pock Champs tournament and is now
a finalist I just picked up chess seven
months ago I'm competing for the hundred
thousand dollar first prize
what the F Pawn is life great question
indeed asking the right questions and uh
We've also got a little uh we're gonna
roll a little thing for uh for Frank
because he's his opponent and uh
hmm this was the moment that he
checkmated saikuno didn't even know that
it was his uh his victory there he um
he won that game by taking literally all
of saikuno's pieces into Vienna
again we've talked about Frank
extensively I think he's also got even
more views than that now a
self-described future Grand Master with
a thousand chess games on chess dot uh
and here he is on stream and Anna today
you and I are going to play a game which
is count the amount of seconds between
Frank says anything and I think the high
score is about one and a half seconds
I do believe you Levy I really do
believe you I've seen a lot of Frank
interviews I've seen a lot of Frank
playing chess and it is to me some of
the most entertaining chess out there
I'm very excited to see this
um I'm very excited as well like I said
it will be a matchup of ghastly like you
know seven months ago is when he learned
chess I think the same for Frank by the
way it was January it was February it
was cold in New York and one day I'm
scrolling on Tick Tock and I see a a a a
loud British teenager just screaming
screaming uh and and and pre-moving and
I go who is this guy and a week later
hikara was reacting to him two weeks
later he was doing a chess lesson with
me months later you know I I commentated
on one of his matches that he played
versus uh another Tick Tock chess player
named orbital racer and
there was 20 000 live viewers like no
embeds twenty thousand people were in
the chat my chat had never moved that
fast uh and it was it was it was
incredible stuff it was incredible stuff
and he he's just taken the world of
Chess by storm so we'll see if he can
keep it up today or if the
If the DJ if the producer of the
musician is uh is going to get the job
done I don't know on paper Frank is the
favorite but ghastly has been an
absolute machine in this event
absolutely I totally agree with you it
seems like ghastly is he getting a
little bit ready I thought he was doing
some stretches or something there to get
ready but I am very excited about this
match the first championship bracket
match it's gonna be absolutely amazing
to see what happens can I ask you Levy
what is Frank's biggest weakness
in chess himself
um Frank's biggest weakness is is
literally just himself uh he none of his
opponents can actually beat him the only
reason that Frank ever loses is because
of himself uh if Frank stuck to the
principles a bit more and if he just
yelled a little bit less he would be
2700 but unfortunately because of those
two things he is an 800 hard stock
player uh we do still cheer for him and
we hope he can you know he can overcome
himself but but there is not a single
player on the planet who can defeat
Frank if Frank is uh a little bit more
contained and a bit more relaxed not
even you no
wow yeah well let's see if ghastly is
able to do so so we got e45939 F6 very
normal opening oh and it's Spanish yeah
Gastly going for a little Rue Lopez I
don't know if either of them are aware
of that uh Frank will just play Knight
F6 Bishop C5 it's going to be all normal
stuff uh I again I don't think they know
that they're playing a Berlin defense
after Knight E4 D4 Knight D6 Bishop D6
DC D5 Knight F5 queen d8 king d8 Etc uh
I think uh you know or we can get the
famous Berlin draw
but um I I don't think we will Levy not
here maybe in the World Cup we will but
not in POG champs yeah yeah not not in
POG Champs definitely not in POG Champs
um
I don't know what the next move is going
to be I mean Frank could see this he is
strong enough
uh you know what let's can we just turn
on Frank's stream I don't even want to
talk just let Frank talk just just put
this production let's just I can take a
break I can go get some tea there is
that a nice move
go there maybe look at a pawn
oh no maybe we just release the beast
you know release the beast of the bishop
but I do want to take that pawn that I
don't know do I take the pawn do I not
take the pawn oh this Pawn that's the
real question do I take it do I not do I
take the pawn or do what you're leaving
a pawn the pawn is the real question
because we've got some pros and cons for
pros like What's the diff I don't know
the difference between pros and cons but
there is a difference between them wait
is bad cons I'll win a Pawn Pros are
winner porn I don't really know oh sorry
did he still not move
no he did not Levy I've been taking some
stretches as well I wonder have you not
taught him this I mean does he know what
he's gonna do here I told you I told you
Frank right here okay
let's keep talking oh
[Music]
okay
okay do I take that pawn I might I do
want to release the bishop okay you know
what I'm sending Frank my book when it's
out okay okay
[Music]
he just spent a minute and a half
developing a bishop I don't even
anyway as I said Frank Is His Own Worst
Enemy Frank is like
he's like a scientist that has won the
highest prizes given out by the
community and he he he refuses to get
out of bed because he can't think of of
the difference in the physical mechanics
of the advantages and disadvantages to
his body of stepping on the floor first
with the right foot or the left foot so
he just lays in bed for hours like Frank
Frank is a is a brilliant man we just
don't quite understand how and why
okay I can see that yeah he seems to
really not be able to decide but now
he's playing a little bit fast well no
no not really he's probably gonna take
his sweet time here too
um but you know he's a perfectionist he
wants to find the best move in the
position and that is admirable yeah it
it is
um the good news is that uh that that
you know he has been finding some very
good moves uh Gastly took his Knight and
then one is Pawn because uh glassly
that's that would be a cool name uh
because Gastly is very practical he just
sees a free Pawn uh Frank could do the
same it's very that is the best move but
but it is very scary because Queen E2 is
very powerful nice way to lose is to
just go Knight F6 Knight C6 discovered
attack and I guess they will find that I
hope Frank castles
um and you mentioned have I taught Frank
this
you know he he knows like I said he he
knows all the stuff like the stuff is in
the brain but
that you know that's not an unreasonable
move but the move d4 is very strong okay
just don't take with the queen like I
taught him you know don't take like you
know because you're gonna get your uh oh
is this a risk
see yeah probably yeah
yes
um
do oh he castled oh oh wow but now the
pawn is is no it's defendable you can go
D3 defend the pawn and now he's got it
yup Tupac he's gonna be two Pawns in the
center and one Pawn up
uh but that's just the pawn and at this
level that makes absolutely no
difference
um no but I I like his development
though like D3 Bishop G5 getting that
Bishop hitting the Knight and then maybe
you can even try to push that E Pawn you
know and develop all your pieces so it
feels like a very nice and natural
position or you can go D4 I guess which
might be even better D4 is not bad at
all just don't go here and get forked
uh the Frank doesn't blunder a lot of
these things because he he's made all
those blunders early in his career like
that's how you have to play chess I mean
you you have to have
a lot of mistakes and you have to get
them all out and then you know you're
not going to be taking stuff like this
uh so he's definitely gonna go Bishop B6
or Rook to d8 which is very tricky he's
dead you know Bishop E4 is
but he's not going to go here because he
sees E5 and because E5 is and they're
that they're my man my man there it is
you're right proven me right nice nice
nice but gas is looking very very very
focused I think it's gonna push that
Pawnee fire
um and just keep it
best move yep
there you go you know maybe Frank will
go out to G4 and and then it's still
game on well just Knight D5 though you
could get overwhelmed with bonds so you
have to be careful
yeah no absolutely Knight G4 but then
the Knight doesn't have that many places
to go to either if it starts getting
kicked out right I mean you don't want
to go back to H6 with the Knight because
then it's gonna get picked up and the
King will get super weak so you got to
be careful with where you go with the
Knight right here
I will play Devil's Advocate and I will
say that even if something like that
happens which is definitely the best
thing for white to do you never know
because all of a sudden black is going
to Checkmate you on the G file because
it's Bob Champs and that's where crazy
stuff happens
um let's I want to see that that would
be really fun to see I want to see that
let's check in on Gastly uh who is
talking a lot less and perhaps using his
words a bit more effectively and
efficiently
he probably isn't the best move I think
I would probably go to I would want to
develop my Bishop first
so it is not a banger
yo this song is fired up
stick that night it's vibing right now
yeah the song is indeed fire as the kids
say
do you not say fire lovey
of course I say what I do you don't
think I'm hip with the lingo of of the
youngins
I am mad cool as the kids say oh no oh
no not the magical I love you I
let's let's let's let's bring it back
real quick I kind of want to analyze
this Gastly has moved his Rook this is
um the computer is kind of a scumbag in
this instance it's uh it's saying a plus
three advantage
but uh but that's only because of like
weird expansions on this side of the
board and if Gastly just plays regular
moves like Knight C3 all his Advantage
will disappear very quickly because
black will go here and then here and
then here and then C5
so
I it's still very very competitive
no absolutely I mean I think that the
evil bar right now it's not really
representing what's truly happening on
the board and we could see that gasly
wanted to play Knight C3 which does look
like a very natural move so this really
could turn around at any moment
um I I really think so Gastly also
wanted to go here which doesn't even
that okay he he developed the bishop I
don't hate that move at all again this
is such a scumbag stockfish thing to do
like the beginner is developing his
bishop and putting it on the most active
square and it's just given a fat
orange question mark like shut up you
don't know me like with how is this a
mistake for the beginner levels you know
what I want I want stockfish adjusted
and a setting enabled for the kind of
level player it's analyzing wouldn't
that be brilliant if it knew the two
800s were playing it would never give
this a question mark
no no I agree but I I guess that the
idea of it is that you're trying to get
out of that you know rating but you know
what I agree I actually agree with you
Levy I think that it's very discouraging
to see this big question mark on your
move which looks completely natural so I
do think that something should be done
about it or maybe you just don't need
the question mark you don't need to say
anything just let that move be just let
that move be now obviously we're
spectating so we see that the players
don't like Frank did not Gastly did not
play this move and get hit with the
question mark because can you imagine
like mid game you're getting insulted I
mean like your your parents do that when
they take you to you know soccer
football practice they just yell you
shoot shoot you know but like stockfish
you can't see because you'd be cheating
anyway we're gonna check in on Frank now
sorry so it's you know buckle up
and not making that oh why is my time so
bad I'm down to under five minutes
already
dear Lord dear Lord okay I want to go
there and threaten that oh this could be
nice if if he leaves that Rook where it
is I can go fretting
oh okay we need to pull my Rook over as
well I did not notice that night
oh goodness me
okay maybe this Frank always get into
time trouble
no this is kind of a new phenomenon oh
that night is looking okay just checking
completely filthy right now absolutely
filthy okay we need to get our Rook
involved right here he's making sense
okay like okay okay
everything he's saying makes sense yeah
the other day I watched him play and he
was talking about being a duck uh no I'm
not hearing that anymore we're gonna go
boom we go there right yeah
surely surely I go there
oh if Bishop moves there though Bishop
could move there
oh then I'll go there then that goes
there then Queen could get involved here
oh I'm seeing two guys I'm scared if I'm
gonna be honest I'm a little scared of
this game right here I'm seeing an
attack here on the Rook Rook could just
be threatened right there then I have to
move back I want to push my Pawn up put
fret on that pawn there okay
okay now I'm gonna push porn there
oh okay yep we're gonna go boom We Go
There wrong put it down Frank put it
down
that's a fantastic Meal look at those
chess principles wow let's bring it back
see this is why we're in the Champions
bracket this is why we're in the
Champions bracket Pawn to C5 bulldozing
the center the C Pawn has backup the C
pawns got back up the C pawns got back
up and just like closely said about an
hour ago she's going for a spicy boom
and let's not tell Frank about the spicy
boom because dear Lord help us that man
is good that man is praying right now
that man is he is going Zen mode ghastly
thinking deep in the tank welcome to the
Champions bracket it's a 50-point gap
between the players and they are showing
it C5 is an excellent move and I think
in the next few moves if Gastly is not
careful he will end up in a worse
position the board is going to open up
for these Bishops and Frank is going to
be in good shape
I think so too I think actually that
Frank is coming back in a very nice way
that C5 move was amazing and the time
difference is not really that far off
either
um Levy I just wanted to ask you are you
ever taking Frank to an over the board
tournament because I really want to see
that happening I really want to see him
play over the board chess I don't know
I'm not his parent I'm not going to
chaperone her but coach aren't you I see
you all them coaching him he he does he
he doesn't really he doesn't ask me any
questions ever all of our coaching has
been me harassing him in DMS I'm like
Frank you gotta practice and he's like
oh yeah and then and then like nothing
happens
um I mean I would love to take him to an
over the board tournament I think he
he's like the third most famous person
in all of England all right there's like
the Prime Minister KSI and Frank I mean
like seriously he yeah he should do a
Frank World Tour it would be incredible
he had to play F6 he had to activate his
pieces now he's so restricted
yeah he's very restricted very passive
move because it's behind the pawn but
it's hard to see F6 looks like a very
very very very very very scary move you
know
yeah it it does you you don't want to
play moves like this you don't want to
open things up for your opponent uh
chat's got me cracking up talking about
frankfur King of England can you imagine
God the press conferences for the king
would be Sensational this man really
said is it a pro or a con I don't know
the difference between a pro and a con
what
oh my God I really want to hear what
he's saying right now he's going all in
Frank is just really doing a speech
right now I want to hear that
timer is Ticky talking down okay okay
this could still be nice
um
okay boom boom does he know that he has
less time than they left
um yeah maybe
okay that goes there that go okay boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom is he
just drawing the legal moves of the
night you you lunatic make a move
this man is just trying to leave
he wants to know where the naked go to
oh my God he's got less he's got he's
got like three minutes on the clock
Frank you just you just gotta go
yeah I'm just gonna go there though yeah
you know could I don't really want to go
there
Frank's parents are watching this and
they are probably stressed they are
stressed yeah I'm gonna go there we're
just gonna hit both nights oh god
um oh God all right all right let's
bring it back let's bring it back it's a
very tense moment in this game for the
last like five moves both players
accuracies have just consistently Fallen
uh because it's a very tense position
now Frank has to has to Wreck it Ralph
the center he's just got to take the
last two moves by white are considered
big X's by the uh computer because
they're considered misses like
apparently this move was very very
strong by white uh and the idea is
essentially that you play this move you
hit the bishop then you trade the queens
and then the bishop slides in uh to to
uh to the DMS over here and uh that's uh
yeah that's that's a very bad situation
for The Rook uh nobody saw that and
Frank has taken on D4 and by the way he
he might do it again he like the goofy
meme from Disney and do it again C5 I
mean it it's it's on the way and a two
and a half minutes four and a half for
gasly this is crazy
now this is absolutely crazy I do think
that he's gonna want to go see five I
mean what otherwise is The Rook doing on
C8 I think he's going to want to push
that pawn but I am a little bit scared
about that Queen being undefended on D7
I mean before we could see it now that
move already happened but I think there
were some tactics there before right the
move before with taking on C5 and then
uh maybe pushing but C5 is played you
know what Gotham you were right you were
right I know my boy I knew it there was
no logic behind this move except I had
one already and I'm going to do it again
that is literally why he played it oh my
God but can you take and then bring the
rook and then just win the piece and a
C5 is an atrocious move in like five
different ways uh you you are a hundred
percent right but this is Pawn Champs
all right the subtlety and another big
hex given that's Family Feud style One X
two x three X's oh my goodness C4 now
but Frank just took one time Anna is he
gonna take again
he might he might take right here I mean
I don't think he's pushing is he pushing
the party is he going C4 I don't think
so
can we like turn him up in this screen
so we don't have to go like to him can
we just quickly see what you say I feel
like he's gonna be yelling about deja vu
I just something I've caught I think
it's called Deja Vu I don't know what it
is but I've been here before
oh my goodness
he took the pawn just like you predicted
and the bishop is gonna come in the
bishop is coming in bring it in fret on
a
um okay that goes there Rook takes there
I'll take there then my Bishop could
okay boo boo we take there right Rook
all right let's mute him real quick and
he's missed it he's missed it oh my
goodness I I apologize for that I know
production is doing their best to keep
up with me uh but uh Frank is uh streams
mostly on YouTube so there is a bit of a
lag but uh so he was talking just
moments ago ghastly has lost the threat
of this game mostly because it's very
complicated and and now it's back to
equal but Frank has a minute and a half
on the clock the accuracy has been
reduced from 80 70 to 55.54 what what is
he took the why why would he okay oh God
is he gonna take this one too just for
no reason why is he giving up he's
taking everything and he almost has to
be Bishop he's seven is coming
why is he just killing office Bishops
they're his best pieces all his other
pieces are in the back rank he can't
play Bishop takes Knight
so nothing Frank the pony too was
completely innocent oh my goodness Frank
just goes to the oh and gasoline
that is ghastly's fifth Miss in the last
eight moves and and now instead of
Bishop E7 winning on the spot for no
reason all he backs up and Frank Frank
is just back in the game
but he's got one minute on the clock
he's got one minute on the clock no
if he wants to Bishop to be back oh my
what what is this why is he weakening
his dark squares he doesn't have a dark
Square Defender oh it's on the board
Knight to G7 Knight to D6 Knight the F6
the dark squares this is gonna cost him
the game and I think it's over for Frank
with one move he lost 12 points of
accuracy oh my goodness
Knight F6 check and then bring up the
queen as well to H4 I mean that pawn on
H7 is gonna be big ah what's happening
Levy that's one of the worst moves I've
ever seen what wait was that a mouse
slip
what he said he's he said you're
attacking my Rook so just take my knight
and maybe
what
I think it's happening love you I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry I know you had a
I mean I'm not rooting for anybody but
frankathan Knight to D7 oh my God but
it's not over six check it's E6 check
Anna and it's not over E6 F6 if you take
with the Knight I might take your queen
that is the only chance he has left E6
is a great move it's the best move on
the board discovered attack
oh okay okay maybe she's just gonna
trade and be a rook up you know queen of
fate and just be a rook up yup yup yup
Queen F6 oh gastly's gonna find
something to F6 for sure
queen of six chat Queen takes Queen Pawn
takes King goes down and then back rank
rookie eight back rank me take take
rookie eight King's gotta go out to H6
um the only chance Gastly has of
throwing this is the way he threw once
the daily dose that is the best move uh
and and he did it by just hanging
something from long range and getting uh
hit in the end game Frank
oh that's it's a Chuck mini one and it's
over right there and it's over big mom
ENT let's go see it on Gastly stream the
instant replay
not my best move but I do take with the
check and I think that is Nate my
friends let's go boom baby
Frank Frank my friend Frank you're
you're a great opponent man
a little bit better
much
this is two oh my goodness sunglasses on
that was one of the craziest middle
games played by any two 800s in a while
and that's saying a lot because I see a
lot of middle games played by 800s one
to nothing Gastly takes the lead the
winner of Group B going strong I mean
listen you emerge from the group of
death
you really have a strong nervous system
and he was just better his mistakes in
this game Anna were missing wins but he
never really lost that much of his
Advantage a couple of times it was plus
one but he was in control for a long
time
yeah no he was absolute control for the
whole time gassy paid really while it
was just missing that Bishop E7 move
um but then he found Bishop H6 so it
didn't really matter that he missed it
and I think it played really well and at
the end I think Frank got really nervous
with his time as well and and everything
started falling apart but yeah ghastly
like we've said he came from the
strongest group of the tournament Group
B
um I mean let me know you must agree
after all of these wins daily dose of
Internet is winning gas is winning I
mean we're gonna see the group b just
just winning I feel like
um and he's just playing really well
he's playing much better than his rating
and he's showing it here yeah I think
sapnap will take down Sea Dog and you
know and gastly's gonna win everybody
from Group B is going to win no
disrespect see dog you know friend of
mine just just got a hype up Group B uh
what a match that was uh Frank was back
in it Frank was actually playing quite
well but he got himself into trouble in
the opening uh however look I will say
the following about probably seven I
want to stat I don't know if the stats
team watches POG Champs or if they only
watch the big tournaments well this is a
big tournament but top level uh well
this is top level chess right I mean to
some people anyway uh how many of these
games are decided with the white pieces
like how many people win with white and
POC jams because I think it's a huge
amount and well Frank is gonna have
white in this game and anything can
happen
anything can happen now Frank needs to
win though to stay in the tournament and
take this to tie breaks
yeah that is exactly right
um we've got some feedback from an
audience member says don't commentate
like these are high rated players just
call the game they're not going to see
every move you do Anna
well now they're not going to see every
move but they're going to see some of
the moves and uh yeah they've played
better than we've thought
yeah
so how about you just we just don't talk
about any of the moves we just
talk about the weather Levy just the
weather how's the weather in New York
it's it's good it's warm you know it's
it's nice uh Frank doesn't remember his
Vienna opening past the second move oh
no he does he was just being loud that I
uh Bishop C4 is great now there is a
line here where if black copies you you
can play Queen to G4
okay that that now Queen if he plays
Queen G4 I'm logging off okay if Frank
plays Queen okay thank you Frank
um solid yeah now it's not even a Vienna
it's just a regular opening but black
kind of blocked in his Bishop Knight F6
is losing now for black
um because of Knight to G5 and it's
basically a fried liver but there's a
pond here and a knight here
yeah okay yeah much slower oh okay
Bishop E6
Bishop E6 is a good attempt if take take
the Knight can't get in
uh yeah and you take some of the center
too I mean it's a little bit scary maybe
that they have Pawn is gone but
sometimes you can have the idea of
pushing that d-pawn yep uh we I've been
informed that we would like to hear
Frank's thoughts
on society and life and culture and art
and Science and business I know this man
is locked straight in right now
um okay I might go do I go there do I go
there I don't do I want to go there
hmm okay yeah I'm gonna trade okay
that's that's not too shabby boom boom
okay we can go take Center
he takes okay boom boom boom boom we
take control
okay that's nice that's nice right there
and now we're gonna go there
okay then we'll go there okay good
position for Frank we're safe right here
this is great I'm loving it
yeah let's let's bring it back uh it's
mostly just a lot of there and there for
now uh and uh this is this isn't this is
instructive because
the person playing with black actually
shouldn't trade this much in the center
they should trade once uh but a lot of
new players they'll sort of trade
everything and the queen is extremely
powerful because the only way to attack
it without a knight is with pawns and
then you just weaken your light squares
daily dose did this earlier uh but he
won anyway uh despite okay Queen D1 is
not
that's not a why is the queen could have
gone to so many better squares the
homecoming of the queen
my friend at least the queen is safe
there but yeah absolutely I mean the
thing there is that the light screws
would have gone very weak and it would
have been nice to see Frank trying to
stop Gastly from castling because that's
like the biggest issue if that light
Square diagonal is open it becomes
harder to Castle but now I guess gas
will just develop nicely Knight F6
Bishop E7 and then it'll just be castles
and it'll be a normal game from there
yep
yup yup yup uh that uh you are right
Queen C4 Queen B for the post some
problems would have been nice and and as
a as a good player at this point already
as a beginner white should be thinking
oh what are my next few moves and and
some of you might think castles but some
of them intermediate players in the chat
will probably think develop my Bishop
out to these squares and long Castle
because then I will get attacking
chances uh Frank didn't do that now
taking this is still good for white
because of the light squares so if he
goes back to D5 or out this way he has
Gucci oh that's a
Queen H5 is like almost
95 Queen H5 I mean that king is not
going to play this
it one last chance Queen H5 Knight D5
he's got to do it now or else this is
happening
you know the queen of seven now
yeah this reminds me of daily doses game
right and he made it work but barely
ah well Frank why would you go oh he
finds it a movie a move late oh he was a
little bit too fast before with the
castles
ah gastly's got to trade queens now and
you know the craziest part after Queen
F7 is
the best move is still Knight D5 oh yeah
because there's a very cheeky Fork
Knight takes F6 you win back upon and
you you get the queen if frankly is
Knight D5 after Queen F7 I I will build
him a statue
but somehow I I don't think
you don't think it's gonna happen
let's check in on Frank
um
if he moves King I can just go there
with night okie dokie
oh okay she does see the idea though oh
look at this me goodness me all right I
he goes there with Queen I take he's
gonna take back with with King then I go
there then maybe start something there
but that doesn't really do anything at
all okay okay that yeah that doesn't do
much at all okay
oh goodness me okay let's just let's get
all those arrows let's get all those
arrows off the table get them all off
the off the screen okey-dokey you know
what we're looking better on time right
now we are looking better on time so we
have got time to work through this game
okay okay now I'm gonna go E7 now do I
give a check there okay this could be
yes this could be nice am I missing
something it's gonna be a Checkmate I
mean the King has to go to d86 there's
Queen out five is winning the Queen the
King has to go to d8 but now there's an
eight takes off six Knight takes F6
Checkmate on the eight
same thing as I'm seeing
yeah I
oh my goodness
but Frank has to finish it off he's
currently at 94 accuracy in this game
it's absolutely amazing now he takes
half seconds he's going to see it
there's no way he doesn't see it Knight
takes half six the king is running away
but the plan that gasly had of going
Queen side castles it's just not gonna
work
Knight takes F6 I mean you can even go
maybe F4 and you can just bring up the
rook and bring everything up
yeah this is this is incredible stuff
uh
uh Queen E7 is the only move and excuse
me keeping the queen on the e-file
yeah to prank Queen EA Checkmate exactly
important right now
and catholic's thinking there's a much
uh faster paced game uh than the last
one
I'm so confused
this is absolutely crazy it looks so
normal in the opening everything looked
so fine but that move Pawn takes instead
of Queen takes opening up the light
Square diagonal just just this this is
the result of that basically so yeah I'm
actually very shocked queenie7
um Frank does find that move very sorry
Gastly does find that move very strong
move and now the Knight has to retreat
so probably 95 the queen will have to
move and I'm thinking that maybe F4 can
be played there although it could get a
little bit scary because the e-pawn
might hang but I mean this is just an
amazing position no matter what
gasoline's not castling and that King is
staying there in the middle forever so
it's a very very very bad long-term
position for gasoline yep and Knight T5
is a great way of handling it
um because
you don't need to win right now like you
didn't have to play Queen G6 uh the the
light squares are permanently damaged
Black's King is stuck in the center and
yeah that was just purely ghastly I
don't know either they're not realizing
uh that he could trade queens or the
power of the or the demand that he could
trade the Queens
um
or or or what uh but
yeah I mean I'm wondering now will Queen
G5 be played
um just to like trade those Queens off
the board
I feel like that's what you should try
to do right now just because of how look
at that and gas he does it he's
realizing that his King is very unsafe
and that those Queens need to get off
the board
now the best move here is not to trade
the Queens white is still better but the
quality of White's Queen is is such so
menacing for black that you should
absolutely not trade you should come
back
put your Rooks in the center play C4 C5
and then uh and and then open up the
king and then Knight to F6 and and and
so on and so forth
um and I'm sure you taught him I'm sure
you taught Frank that you should never
trade queens and in winning attacking
positions right Navi
I but probably but you know uh you could
also you could use the argument here
that I'm up material so I should trade
Queens right like I'm above on so I'm
gonna trade the Queens uh but uh but
that's wrong in this case it supersedes
that your queen is too strong and by
removing your queen from the board
winning an end game up a pawn is
a lot harder uh than it is to Checkmate
a person with a queen and a knight and
you know a bunch of activities so in
chess there is some
he takes it Frank takes the queen and
the important thing right now is the
fact that Frank cannot draw he needs to
win to stay in the tournament if he
draws he loses the match and he's out of
the tournament so it's important now for
Frank to win which becomes harder with
the Queens off the table you
becomes a lot harder
uh the game plan with no Queen now for
white is
put as many pawns on light squares as
possible to sort of negate the movement
of Black's Army and then try to expand
over here using your Pawn majority and
space Advantage plug the hole on F5 just
jump there exert pressure this bishop
can't really come out
but the subtleties to win an end game
are significantly more difficult
and and Frank's last name is not Carlson
so it's going to be a long way it's
going to be a long way to win that game
it is and I mean all of those plans they
they feel very difficult for you know
this level I mean it's it's very
difficult to know all of that
um so he's trying to get a wrecking ball
they don't know why he brought that Rook
all the way here kind of blogging is
that one Rook from moving but I guess it
just wants to go rookie three bring the
Rook up place it on G3 threaten that G5
pawn and but you know it's very easily
defendable so I'm actually not really
sure what the plan is let me
many me too me too uh but let's let's uh
let let's check in on the players maybe
the players can guide us
maybe the players can guide us a little
bit
Surety like he he's gonna play C6 he's
gonna kick the Knight out
and like Frank at this point needs to go
where do I want my knight
you know and Frank frequently does good
things but in one move bursts
you know and uh
and gastly's gonna be like well I want
to reroute my knight to that square I
want to play G4 so I could activate the
bishop on the diagonal you know
um that would be really good G4 here
would be well I guess it also makes the
pawn a little bit weaker though right
yes it does make the pawn weaker it's
true it is true Rook to d8
I wonder if we're going to see Rook of
three Rook F7 but obviously now there's
always Rook D solving so even if the
Rook tries to come in there I feel like
Frank is the kind of guy that wants to
put his Rook on Seventh so I feel like
he might try to do that but there's not
really any big threats with that
gasoline can just always trade
it's Frank C 92 Knight G3 Knight F5
no way I think she does is she going for
a three-step reroute to the F5 Square
where his Knight will live on an outpost
that the opponent can't get rid of and
exert pressure into the black position
is that oh that is a great move by the
way from Gastly and the one of the best
options here for white is to just ignore
it just leave it alone
but
okay fine all right let's let's let's
let's see what Frank is thinking
oh time's against us once again time is
not in our favor
oh goodness me that's a little bit of a
cheeky cough right there okay
it's like a small cough again we are
down by pretty much a full minute right
here
um
oh I should have double stacked the
Rooks uh that's fine
not really that fine is it
um can't take there
um
okay boom I go there maybe boom I go
oh goodness me okay yeah we're gonna go
there next
then
attack there that moves down maybe there
was that Rook
okay we're looking to get rid of that
Bishop
Bishop can go there do I go there maybe
no I can't I've got to go there
um oh
okay okie dokie now we're gonna go boom
we'll go there next
all right yep we're gonna go there next
okay okay yeah we do go there right yeah
boom we're gonna go there
um oh I do see a tactic he could make
right here I might need to pull my
what is the tactic he sees right here
or I might need to go
okay that's
groundbreaking stuff by the way he he
discovered the light Square blockade
this is amazing and black now is
struggling which is why in a lot of
these end games the bishop should try to
be on the opposite color of the Pawns
because we see the bishop is sort of
stuck here and it's just a pawn
essentially
um best move for white create a light
squared structure slowly Advance with
the king and the pawns that I wouldn't
have played that move but the position
is good enough that it's fine and then
maybe he will reroute there where he
will blockade yeah I don't know is he
going Knight C1
that would be epic I mean we did see
Frank looking at all the ways the Knight
can move before so I feel like he's
really into the night right now like he
really wants to move it around and get
some good stuff with it so he might be
doing that
yeah Knight here
and all of this
the question is what is ghastly's plan
right now what is he trying to do is he
going to try to double up his Rooks on
the H file but that's very easily
stoppable I mean I was thinking if it
doubles up the rocks and then tries to
look towards H2 if H3 try to get G4 in
somehow but you can't because the Rook
is on e4 which is a fantastic Square for
Frank's Rook
uh and ghastly okay Gastly plays Rook to
D7 that he could be doubling here he
could be doubling here I like that he's
not over committing anything wolf Frank
play Knight to C1 or is he going for
Pawn to C3 uh very delicate position
Frank is down a minute
three minutes versus four
so I'm getting into very lit category
chass
yeah absolutely and then after that very
quickly will be uh it will be bullet so
.
the one on the board the backwards
reroute to go to D3 Frank Magnus Carlson
Woodley oh my goodness
is incredible what
Frank you're right Frank is a genius
Levy what's going on here oh my goodness
Knight to C1 to blockade and apply
pressure Knight to C1 might win him the
game just don't hang the Rook you could
take it's a great move from Gastly
trying to remove the blockade rookie one
is nice that's also good now Frank could
go here but then E4 is an issue Knight
C5 is a fork rookie seven and then I
don't even know rookie one oh my
goodness white is winning but anything
can happen Anna absolutely anything can
happen but can I just say I I'm really
liking also how ghastly saying Frank's
ideas and he's just stopping them now
when the work is not an effort like you
said those pawns are free to push so the
whole idea of Frank's idea of pushing
back the Knight to reroute it is not as
good anymore and I think this is now a
much easier game for Gastly to play over
here yeah it definitely is uh and uh
Frank might have just forgotten that
that was his idea at all I mean he might
remember it because the bishop sees the
Knight but I'll be very sad if Frank
goes over here instead uh Gastly is
playing Super well for being a pawn down
but the reality is he is still down upon
him he cannot make forward progress if
white play he did it lovey he forgot he
had too many thoughts in his head uh
yeah but it doesn't matter like again if
he brings his King and puts all plays on
the light squares and and does a good
job you know uh he he might still he
might still win the Knight versus Bishop
end game but the bishop is better than
the knight in the end game it's just
faster
and with the Rook too typically Bishops
and Rooks work better with each other
because they both are uh long range
pieces right they can help each other
out
yep yep two and a half minutes for Frank
Gastly down to three it's a super tense
you can't ask for a better matchup uh
Beast oh my God ghastly restricting the
movement of this Knight good Lord oh my
goodness gasly with B6
this is a 2000 gamer witnessing Levy
maybe combined but uh you know that
still gives them 200 Points each right
like uh this is yeah okay I I I hate
that move because even though this trade
is happening the E Pawn becomes a passer
yeah yeah and we saw in the other game
with daily does what those passers can
do they are strong very strong yep oh
but but but Anna Frank's got two Pawns
of his own now I mean this is this this
is wild
I'm just the black spots are closer you
know to promoting I hope Frank doesn't
go here and get hit with a check and an
infiltration I mean he's still doing
fine but King G2 Rook F7 Rook F1 and if
you trade there white is winning because
the two pawns are massive in a knight
versus Bishop end game Rook F7 Rook F1
very natural continuation and then if
Gastly trades he is losing chances
increase by 10x
this is actually and the question is if
they know it right that's the question
but those past Pawns in a rook last end
game are gonna be amazing those white
pawns I mean I think we might be
witnessing this Levy Rook off one and I
can see them trading yeah it doesn't
look so scary but that H Pawn in that g
Pawn those pawns are going to places
yes they are let's check in on ghastly
let's see how he's feeling does he know
he's defending does he think he's he's
losing what does he think
amazing he that me too I agree
the music does the talking for him
I do like his music though this is the
kind of music I listen to when I play
chess
if I come up to check
uh he wants to trade good move by Frank
what yep we take positions
oh and he's going for the trade and if
he
'll take it
wow he's played it let's bring it back
to the analysis board you are about to
be in in shock my friends when the move
Rook F1 was played Rook F7 was played I
told you it was equal and after a rook
trade it would be a tenfold Advantage
for white and after just a few more
moves the position is officially plus
five for Frank because trading a rook in
an end game that leaves Knight and five
versus bishop and four is not what you
should be doing and also these two pawns
are lethal these pawns are stopped by
this Army of pieces and Frank is in good
shape he can take this and he can just
go
yeah no this is now completely winning
for Frank I mean he just needs to push
the pawns he doesn't need to do anything
else he just needs to push the pawns
maybe the H1 first but yeah this one was
called a mistake it was better to push
the outer one because it's just further
from the action uh and that now the
bishop is completely sealed off there
he's going and after King to E6 G6 or
default it's better to play D5 case
pushing everything now he's got to push
this because he he's got to give
everybody a chance if he plays H5 or G6
I there it is beautiful and now when
this King goes here there there it is
and the King can't stop both Anna
wow wow I mean I feel like we should
almost check out Frank to see if he
really sees that he's winning this I
think he should yes it looks like he's
eating his camera or microphone let's
see
[Music]
that pawn up there oh yes oh yes come on
come on to Heaven Thomas
come on we can do this go on you pause
go on come on we could do this we can do
this you have neighbors
that
that we win a porn
of G6 oh
there it goes there it goes yes yes
come on
yes we've got this oh my goodness come
on baby get me that Queen
of it Frank pre-move it Frank G8 Queen
Frank put it on the board baby
bring the king closer it's just a king
and queen mate no no checks needed okay
oh my goodness let's bring this back to
the analysis board it was moments away
from a mate there he could have made it
oh god oh Anna Anna he keeps talking
about not stalemating he he keeps
talking about not stalemating oh this is
so scary
um
I'm gonna make another one
I mean it's so fine okay
take any tail come on come on baby
um oh my goodness Frank don't take his
pawns Frank don't take his pawns oh
got it oh God he's gonna stalemate him
if he takes his Pawns
I can't watch for the B6 Pawn oh my God
this spot is not hurting you right now
don't take the phone Frank we can't
afford to stay mate it's not the pond
it's not the pond Pawn just don't take
the pawn
all right
um then we're gonna go there give a
check
don't take the pawn oh my God this is
nuts he's dancing in between the king
and the pawn and the night okay it's
main two queen C4 Queen A4 Quincy
Queen A4 is made in two it's on the
board
right here
nice yes
think oh that's what you want last one
Frank one to one with Gastly and we have
our first championship quarter final tie
break buckle up ladies and gentlemen
because the deciding game will be a
three minute game of chess with a five
second bonus this is wild stuff Gastly
has been there before he was a double
overtime participant uh versus sapnap
and a single participant in the overtime
versus virtual uh the person playing
with the white pieces is determined by
the person with the higher accuracy in
the two matches which I'm not gonna lie
Anna is gonna be frank because that
first game was utter nonsense and Frank
just scored 85 on game two which means
that's bad news for gasly he might be
facing elimination after emerging from
the group of death this is wild stuff oh
my goodness this is incredible I mean I
can't even stop smiling from that
reaction from Frank like that that was
just absolutely incredible so we're
gonna get the game going very soon uh I
I have just been told that despite Frank
having a higher accuracy between the two
matches his accuracy versus ghastly was
only five percent points higher and in
game number one ghastly's accuracy was
nearly 12 points higher which means that
on the average gasly is playing white
his average accuracy was three to four
percent higher on average between the
first two games and that means that
gasly gets white even though Frank had
the overall highest accuracy it's the
average of the two games and Gastly was
more accurate
whoo that is crazy but this game that
Frank played I mean this was beautiful
this end game absolutely amazing that's
the way it's supposed to be played all
the pawns go boom boom boom boom boom
going all the way to the other side just
like Frank was saying and that was just
incredible oh my goodness it was
incredible but the good news is it
doesn't matter who's white and black in
the blitz uh it really doesn't matter
Frank is an experienced Blitz player I
see the chat yelling rigged what do you
mean this isn't a football league we
don't even have referees it's just the
cap score I mean it literally is a
numeric quantitative analysis of a chess
game there's no VAR all right you just
you all just mad all your football clubs
never win a damn trophy anyway Knight F3
Knight C6 and here we go it's another
Spanish it's three minute chess Frank
has no time to blabber or he will lose
on time
no no he needs to keep his columns here
and uh I mean he's a nurse and he needs
to just have a clear path of thought
that's gonna be important here
what is he
think about what is he doing
it's room three
what is 30 seconds to just play just
play just play whatever you want to play
Frank oh my God what is he doing he's
just clicking the moves
oh no it's the bishop again this one
took him two minutes before Levy
[Music]
openings in the blue playoff of pot
Champs
I think he is a little bit of creativity
doesn't hurt anyone right what is he
doing why is he playing Knight to D4
he's never played in his life
[Laughter]
Gastly off yeah yeah it probably will
this is called the bird defense of the
rui Lopez it is trash it is not good at
all and I don't recommend it for
beginners it is not a move but but Frank
is completely fine on the line of board
we'll pull it up I I don't want Frank
here for the whole commentary for the
whole Blitz game
um yeah a knight to D4 is uh is just not
a thing it's just not a thing I mean it
you know because you could just take and
then but Frank is fine Anna he he's fine
and he's he's playing All the Right
Moves b5a5 and Frank is fine that is
crazy I mean he's just really going for
those Pawn storms again right just like
in the previous game he saw his pawns
pushing and winning now he's doing the
exact same thing B5 A5 and that Bishop
might even get trapped on B3 yeah and
look at this D6 excellent stuff Knight
F6 and then castles this is an excellent
position for Frank
this is amazing are you sure he hasn't
studied this are you sure this is not he
wasn't just trolling us and this is his
secret prep hell no he doesn't study
anything but what I will tell you is
that he is a genius because ghastly is
going to go take take try to trade the
bishop and probably hang Bishop takes B2
all right Frank is maintaining the
tension that is a sign of an advanced
beginner he's an early intermediate he
didn't just take at first availability
instead he's gonna go here and take and
then he's in a castle this is crazy
stuff oh my goodness I don't think gas
is taking though I think the bishop is
coming out to G5 I think he's gonna
develop and that he's not gonna take or
at least some at least some at least I'm
hoping so but Frank's got this D6 pawn
and E5 you can't push I mean Frank what
on Earth Frank played the birds defense
of the Lopez great great call by the way
H6 now is probably what I would play if
I'm Frank but I'm not Frank so I have no
idea what I would play
um and then if the bishop goes here you
could even play G5 I mean if you really
want to get cheeky with it
yeah yeah and we all know that Frank uh
does get cheeky with this move so he
goes castles instead a little bit more
of a Savor Savor safer move and now I
think that we're gonna see gas is just
getting the night out okay no he does
take the pawn just like you said and
it's crucial that he doesn't blunder the
pawn on B2 he needs to go something like
Knight C3 after this yeah I don't know
what Frank is thinking about now Knight
to C3 exactly ghastly will definitely
see this so it'd be a really bad time to
just play a completely okay now Frank
loves taking Knights like he loves it
but you know what would be a gangster
move Queen A5 hitting this this and
that's Queen A5 would if if Frank plays
Queen A5 he wins pot Champs but okay
I'll take B5 also a great move and he's
going B4 and he's gonna try to take this
Pawn
oh he's going for the pawn he's going
for the pawn but there's Knight A4 the
pawn can't be saved although there will
be a lot of very very very undefended
pieces like that Bishop on G5 so we will
see a little bit I do like Frank's
position a lot this is this is an
amazing opening I mean are you gonna
play this yourself Levy the birds
opening in the in the room open
um yeah I'll play it in my next game I
mean I I like to play a lot of different
stuff like the schliemann or the yanish
I've never played the bird because it's
garbage but you know it's not garbage in
this game uh and what is ghastly
analyzing he only has two Bishop moves
when you have two minutes on the clock
in a Blitz game you cannot spend 25 of
your time on a retreating move because
you don't know which one is better so
we're gonna look at Gastly now
but I don't think we're gonna get much I
think he's just laser focused
I think it's shocked by this opening
he's never seen this before
okay he's not saying anything just get
let's get it back he retreated his
Bishop finally but he did it with a
minute and a half on the clock we get
now we can't just have an energy drop
like that you know what I'm saying like
he's not even he is both players are so
nervous Anna too because they and they
they show it in different ways Gastly
shows it like an adult he keeps
everything inside all right he doesn't
have a release and Frank's just
screaming the whole time B4 on the board
you're really pushing for gasoline's
maturity aren't too Levy but now the
pawn on B2 is hanging now Frank can go
Bishop takes B2 and all his dreams will
have come true yep and I think that
castle is very upset I don't think it's
happened with this position whatsoever
at all Frank seems to have gone the
absolute best out of this opening the
bishop has to move and he just has to
not blunder anything whilst he's doing
that yeah and he goes back but now F4 or
D4 are trapping the bishop in the center
of the board but there is Bishop H2 King
H2 Knight to G4 the best move is to not
take it's to leave the bishop there is
is Gastly gonna find these moves he's
now down 40 seconds on the clock this is
his biggest time disadvantage of the
entire day oh my God he makes a move on
the opposite side of the planet
well he's going for that C6 pawn and
he's gonna have the same threats but
yeah the bishop over there this was not
what the what the real plan was in this
position yep and now there is station
takes H2 now yes yes but Frank was more
concerned with with that F4 has been
wow
for now you can
continue it's ghastly who is winning
takes an E5 and and Frank is completely
lost in that position
she won't see it I mean that's the
reason the bishop is on G5 push the pawn
Gastly yup push it push it two Bishops
broken structure Rook before Rook D4 on
the board E5 is is gonna land gasoline
in a completely okay he's taking this
Frank's gotta deal with this pin he's
got to deal with this pin
this is a crucial pin right now but
there's just so many pawns hanging as
well
Queen A5 only chance Queen A5 Rook D4
Queen C5 pinning The Rook uh ah it's the
queen but Bishop F6 is winning now
Bishop F6 will I see it right here right
now maybe he'll take the bishop and see
the pin but that would not be as good he
needs to take the Knight here yes you're
right he's down to 30 seconds oh my God
he's winning but he's down to 30 seconds
a little time he's so nervous probably
what's he gonna do what's he gonna do 20
seconds oh gosh we're about to see chaos
they're both gonna make so many mistakes
right now Queen to B3 Frank has a minute
and five seconds Bishop E2 doesn't even
create a fork does he play H6 does he
play Rook B8 what's he gonna do oh my
goodness one minute remaining for Frank
and 24 seconds for Gastly Bishop to E6
is a fantastic move
very nice the queen is hanging again
guess who needs to move the queen queen
B2 very nice
looking at a pawn on D4 I mean Frank's
gotta deal with the pin yup and now
they're gonna start trading they're
gonna start trading everything will
Gastly find Queen takes Pawn by the way
that would be uh that would be
completely ridiculous if he finds that
with 20 seconds on the clock and he's
found it oh my god wow he's not going
for the trace I thought he was gonna do
it because of his time but he got
nervous and wanted to just trade
everything off but no
yep Rook to d8 on the board Bishop F6 oh
my God is Gastly gonna find Queen takes
F6 and F5 that's the reason he did it
Queen takes F6 is Take On The Rook is
coming in Rook of three Rook G3 F5
everything absolutely everything F5
Queen G5 F6 yeah I've been instructed
that we're gonna go to gasly but he not
saying much but
foreign
I guess we just commentate over him I
don't I don't know Queen G5 check F5 F6
is it's what you said Queen F6 Rook F3
Rook G3 we might be seeing some final
moments here
this might be
oh he's trying to trade the Bishops or
or no no he's switching ideas he's
finding the better plan
look at that Navi
oh my god wow
King H1
we go up six now okay he's giving a
little space for the king yeah yeah he's
not getting back ranked checkmated oh my
gosh so much has happened okay so he
played H4 which whatever stockfish can
can eat a Frank uh no no no no no no uh
no no pun intended Rook to G8 uh and
then uh Queen F6 Jack oh my God pawns
are just falling off over here gasly is
winning because he's a pawn up and black
cannot defend his King successfully Rook
G7 and there's Queen H4 oh my gosh he
can move the Rook now Anna any there's
no pin anymore
E5 maybe he can go E5 E5 here maybe
eight there's Queen A8 oh my goodness
Queen A5 Frank could sneak it on the
back right oh this is so close
oh this is crazy I don't know who's
gonna win anymore Levy I have no
absolute clue of who's winning this game
at this point in time and but but Frank
now was he's got to be thinking to to
get in there with the queen queen A5
Queen to E1
all right but it does leave the pawn
hanging on D6 you know that's the scary
part about it so he goes Queen G8 inside
looking at G2 oh my God that that's
terrifying oh Queen he said
Queen moves on this diagonal to cover
Rook to G1 because if he goes Rook to F1
I think there's a win with Queen G4
Queen H3 maybe no but there's backtrack
problems never mind I can't get ahead of
myself maybe Queen A8 or something in
the future I think it's gonna go Rook F1
Rook F1 looks like the very natural move
here but he has very little time 20
seconds on the clock he needs to stop
the Checkmate right here right now
otherwise he's out of the tournament why
why why is Rook F1 not being recommended
wait what
the queen
what why did he do that oh my goodness
but don't go Bishop G4 because after oh
that's a great move and now the only
chance gasoline has gasoline can just
mate him back rank but if Frank makes a
left for the king it is over it is over
and Frank is going to move on there are
still ways to lose there are still ways
to lose I can't exactly find them I
can't find I'm looking for the man I'm
looking for the ways to throw this game
it has to be the backgrounds maybe the
pins oh so beautiful oh that's that's so
beautiful that might be it the only
chance he has now is to sneak in but as
long as Frank doesn't panic speaking of
Frank can we check in on him I know
there's a delay but but like I just want
to see his reaction
Queen G5 is vicious here I don't know if
we're gonna go to Frank we might not we
might not need to okay we're going to
him it's a little behind but how are his
emotions okay now we're gonna go there
we're gonna get a nice little Fork off
okay boom will go there he goes there I
can go there and get a delicious Fork
holy okay he's looking for a mate holy
guacamole come on
we're so close
we're so close we're gonna get we're
gonna get a mate Maybe
oh yeah always wow then what's the Rook
oh yes okay
um
um okay now we're gonna go there okay
okay boom we go there give a check
then we're gonna go there no threefold
no free no threefold repetition Frank
Frank you draw this game by threefold
repetition I will eat my shirt don't
even
don't threefold Frank don't go for
another check oh my God oh my God
threefold oh God you can't repeat the
position he can't repeat the position
this is completely insane this is
completely insane oh my God he's gonna
draw the game
now
oh my God
you can think it doesn't have to do this
oh my God Frank don't make a draw Frank
don't make a draw Bishop has he made
three full repetition yet oh my God he's
got to push upon or something oh no come
on just move there Bishop just don't
move the queen oh my oh it's mate made
it one push three
okay
yes
oh holy guacamole
holy guacamole they've all well played
well played oh I was run for my money
right there I was completely run for my
money completely and utterly run
for my money completely and utterly run
for my money
completely and utterly what run for my
money and yet despite being thoroughly
and completely run for his money
Frank is our first semi-finalist
in the championship bracket by winning
two to one in a tie break Blitz game
versus Gastly
oh my God Anna I am out of worth
wouldn't that he played so well I mean
wow this
this is insane but that comeback that
Frank was able to do at the end was just
absolutely insane I mean this is
probably gonna be pretty devastating for
it Gastly to see what advantage he had
but he played so well what an intense
match we had Lavi yeah that was uh that
was absolutely Sensational stuff you
really just and you are gutted for gasly
because he beat he was leading one to
nothing I mean in this match and uh wow
what more to say uh we are going to try
to obviously get an interview with Frank
uh I really hope Gastly joins us because
he he's just a pleasure to talk to and
uh
what a match today I mean really really
what a match it was just a quick uh
reminder at what the championship
bracket now looks like Frank is moving
on to face the winner of xqc versus Papa
Plata what an arc six months ago Frank
did not exist on the internet and he
might get a game against the biggest
streamer I don't know I mean again it's
all relative like you know kai gets a
lot of viewers as well but you know xqc
like I'm a twitch OG so for me he's
still
he's still uh he's still got them in my
opinion I still call him the biggest
streamer but that would be absolutely
nuts or Papa Plata right obviously or
Papa Plata but xuc is a big favorite in
that matchup so we will see no
disrespect whatsoever to the competition
uh we're going to go for a very short
break and we are about to interview both
players podcast 5 will wrap up in a few
minutes don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples
under promotion as we said is the
process of promoting a pawn but not to
the most obvious or most powerful type
of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kromnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a night that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the a4e8 diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
baby
[Music]
check this out
welcome back everyone to our final match
of the day as we see Frank with the
walk-off
punching of the air the air had
absolutely zero chance and we are lucky
enough to be joined by both Frank and
gasly gentlemen thank you for a classic
that was Sensational to watch I have
nothing but respect to the two of you I
could sense uh Anna and I could sense
the nerves in the last game and just the
adrenaline so I just want to start with
Frank congratulations how do you feel
tell me uh tell me how the match was uh
was in your eyes
I'm always scared the entire time I I
was scared to make any moves on the
board I just I didn't want to blunder
and I was oh my God it was scary it was
very first the entire match but
I won so I mean great from ghastly
absolutely superb
that Gastly just same question to you uh
you know you you really never had any
easy matches in this event like from
daily dose to Virtual to sapnap to now
your first matchup in the championship
bracket I'm I'm gutted for you because I
I know how crazy the journey was and I
kind of wanted the Cinderella story to
continue uh to take take me through how
the match was for you
oh sure I mean you know coming out of
the gate with the wind I was really
really excited and confident and it felt
you know like I I was going to be able
to handle the rest of the matches but
Frank you've definitely done a lot of
practice he's gotten so much better
um even after analyzing his games
there's still so many things that he was
doing differently and much more
efficiently so I'm really really stoked
on him for that
um and uh overall I mean it was a really
really intense match and I I had a lot
of fun but like Frank said I was
terrified too man it was
Castle you've improved so much he only
started playing chess seven months ago
and you've been playing some great chess
in this tournament I can even see some
chess boards in your background do you
think you're gonna keep on playing chess
after POG Champs oh absolutely
absolutely
um
sorry
no go on go on sorry oh I was just gonna
say it's not something that I'm doing
you know just for fun I really love it
and I think it's something that I'll do
for the rest of my life and uh you know
it's it's brought me a lot of a lot of
exciting things like that just being in
this uh tournament in general has been
so fun and by the way Frank
um I went three I went 3-0 on all my
matches and I'm honored that it was you
the the loudest person in chess to take
me out
thank you thank you
oh well you were incredibly difficult
opponent incredibly delightful respect
yeah there was there was a lot of
a lot of momentum coming up uh
considering Gastly you emerged from the
the group of death like there was no
easy matchups in that group
uh and uh yeah you won the first game
right it was it was a it was a very very
very close one and I just want to say
that uh it's it's a beautiful thing that
you learned chess seven months ago and
like you're this motivated and uh if
you're ever new in New York uh I'm more
than happy to play you uh in chess and
help you continue that Journey so
um yeah it was uh it was it was amazing
to get an opportunity to uh to
commentate this
um and I I mean Frank
what's uh do you know you got you got
any plans for your next opponent you're
just gonna get some sleep you're gonna
do any practice what's uh you're playing
the winner of xqc versus Papa Plata you
know any of those guys you watch any of
those guys what's The Scouting Report
looking like
um well uh I don't really watch either
of them but I'm gonna have to watch them
now
um but yeah I've only seen like one clip
of xqc I I don't and I haven't seen any
of papillet so I'm gonna have to do my
homework that's what we have to do
that's beautiful just call him Papa let
that's his new name since you said it he
is now popular that's that's what we're
gonna call him now just don't don't call
him pop either that yesterday and that
was terrible just don't do that that's
the only one
um amazing amazing uh oh I love you
Ashley I'll definitely oh definitely
pick you up on that uh that chess
opportunity I'd love to play a few games
against you I'm pretty sure I got a show
in New York coming up so I'll come out
and you know hit you up
let's do it let's do it that's uh that's
that's that's beautiful
um I I was just gonna ask you uh before
before we wrap up with you guys I know
you're not participating in the rest of
the bracket but who do you predict is
going to be the champion of POG Champs
five as Bittersweet as it might be hey
that's that's fine with me I knew what I
was getting into and there was a chance
I'd lose and that's fine I accepted the
whole way I had a really fun Journey
what a blast but you know who it
better be it better be you Frank you
better take this dub bro if you
don't oh I'm gonna come all the way to
I'm gonna come across the pond I will
find you I will find you
honestly and then not win the whole
thing
the pressure's on I'm gonna try when I
try with me Godly I'm gonna promise I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it okay I'm
Gonna Keep Your I'm gonna keep your word
on that I'm gonna keep your word on that
oh I'm gonna put everything into it I'm
gonna do 90 more effort this time I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it for you guys all
right um
do it do it for the memes
for the dubs
Frank the pressure is on
Gastly I suppose the pressure is off
it's a bittersweet ending but uh
I can get back to writing now so that's
that's actually kind of nice I've been
putting writing music off just to
practice so now I can finish my album
chess does have that effect you stop
doing everything and you instead do
chess and let me tell you even as a
person whose job it is it's sometimes
very uh it's uh it's a it's a tough uh
tough space to operate in so uh wish you
all the best uh with the writing looking
forward to the new music and we will all
collectively cheer on Frank because you
can't just beat the winner of Group B
and not win the whole thing gentlemen
I'm gonna we're gonna let you go thank
you so much both for joining us all the
best to you both thank you
and we will hopefully see you very soon
all right cheers everybody have a good
one
bye guys thank you bye
we see one more time we're gonna take a
look at our brackets first the
constellation I know that neither of
these players participated in this
bracket but we have squeaks moving on
today after a win over foosli daily dose
of Internet moving on after a win over
Jarvis that was a very close match uh
and uh We've also got
oh we've got amazing we've got we've got
squeak celebrating and here's gonna be
the second one ready ready is the gonna
be the exact same or did we not put back
to back I just sell a thumbs up oh he's
got to make that his chess.com profile
photo or an emote what an emote that
would be the thumbs up
two an animated one yup Frank oh that's
that's it right there that's that's POG
rage right there
in the webcam oh he's not gonna sleep
tonight incredible stuff and our
Championship bracket the only man
emerging thus far to the semi-finals is
Frank and it just hit me that if Frank
wins his next matchup I will meet that
man in Los Angeles that is crazy oh my
goodness Frank in person I hope he's got
a passport imagine he doesn't have a
passport or something oh my goodness
what a day what a day I think you're
gonna meet him at Levy in person him
playing chess in L.A against the pogchan
finalist I mean that is like a dream
come true will he scream in the venue oh
my God that's a great question he's he's
never played chess on a camera outside
of his room so are they gonna allow him
to scream will they just isolate him in
a location live in Los Angeles to stream
at the top of his lungs I don't know are
they gonna make him be quiet it's almost
worth the whole trip Kelly just to watch
that
wow I don't know I didn't even think of
that I did not realize that there was a
whole live final this is crazy stuff
what a development I don't even
wow they're gonna have to answer that
question uh we have more matches for you
uh not today that that's not a surprise
but we do have more matches on Monday we
like to give you the weekend off and
also all of the streamers uh we've got
Papa Plata taking on xqc in the
championship quarterfinals that is going
to be Group D versus Group C and the
winner of that match will play Frank and
we've also got virtual versus saikuno in
the consolation quarterfinals we've seen
that the winner of that matchup uh we
will take on I believe squeaks if I am
not mistaken then we've got cutie
Cinderella versus Ginny and we will end
the day with I did a thing who is
probably the second most jacked
participant in this event uh and versus
tyler1 so that's gonna be a whole lot of
fun who do you have any any predictions
oh there's a fifth one I forgot
oh my goodness I I forgot poor poor Sea
Dog and sapnap finish I thought it was a
four match today there's five matches
there are five matches Sea Dogs
amazing day I mean my goodness
what a day that is maybe epic yeah well
I honestly I mean right now I am
actually rooting for Frank this whole
thing made me go full on I'm gonna root
for Frank but I do still think that Sea
Dog is one of the favorites but I don't
know who's gonna win pot Champs who do
you think Levy prediction right here
right now who's the winner of pogchem's
five
foreign
that man is gonna clutch it versus
virtual and he's gonna clutch it versus
Sea Dog and he's gonna clutch it versus
Frank and he's gonna
he's gonna win Park Champs five I'm
calling it right now the winner of that
matchup Sea Dog versus sapnap is the
winner of podcast five what about you
what if xqc would win pogchamps five
imagine that imagine the story he's
played Four podcasts and now he's coming
back with the fifth one and he wins the
whole thing he has been playing well
when he's really focused and
concentrating he's playing some great
chess
I can see that happening Lavi I don't
see it as impossible this year I really
don't I really don't I it's not
impossible that's the incredible thing I
just yelled a sentence and guess what I
don't even fully believe it that's that
that's not even my prediction watch this
Frank will win pot Champs five like you
don't know that like I I have no idea
but that's the amazing thing we're gonna
have more match coverage for you on
Monday we're gonna clear out all of the
brackets into the semi-finals it's going
to be five matchups 10 players and we
will know who is in the consolation
semis and the championship semis
this has been so much fun we are about
to wrap up the day but first
we will tell you about some incredible
twitch drops
all right we've got these incredible
twitch drops for you and uh they were
actually going to tell me what to talk
about them but they wrote me about the
bullet Chess Championship but I can tell
you about that too you should join I I'm
waiting for
don't miss your chance to go just like
I'm twitch drops earned two weeks of
diamond membership by watching two or
more hours of chess with participating
streamers on Twitch you must connect
your tuition chess.com accounts to claim
the reward drops will only be available
for a limited time so don't miss it
like they missed giving me the CTA use
exclamation point drops in the chat to
learn how
wow I have never been more terrified
than when I have to talk about something
and I don't have a script that was scary
Anna just be glad that that was not you
yeah but you did great you did fantastic
Levy it was amazing and great voice as
well you know great voice read that was
great
uh yeah this uh the show was great the
games were great uh it was a blast
commentating we will not have Fox Champs
on the weekend so you can leave the
house touch some grass uh for legal
reasons we're not responsible if you are
allergic to it and get an allergic
reaction pogchamps five will resume on
August the 7th that's Santa crumbling
I'm Olivia Rosman we will see you on
Monday
get out of here
bye oh no that's not what I told you to
do no you don't want that that's it it's
so simple
oh my goodness
maybe he won't see it easy
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
dusting off his hands oh
hey
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
get out
[Music]
let's go
like
this album
foreign
[Music]
thank you